Didn't two,
one,
boom,
and we're live.
Let's go.
Let's go chat.
If you said anything else other than
let's go champions.
The first thing you said in the podcast
will be a giant.
We had to start it off,
right?
The chat.
Shannon,
how did you get started doing this man?
That is the you would you would think
that that something like as simple as
let's go champ,
like that wouldn't catch on.
How would that be?
So inspirational videos every day.
I get pumped up.
Thank you brother.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
A pleasure meeting you.
Find on youtube as well,
champ.
Let's go champ.
I appreciate this.
Oh,
I made it.
I'm here with you.
Your videos on instagram get me fired
up.
They're positive.
They're exciting.
They're fun.
Infectious,
real.
It's real.
It's real me.
It's me.
I've been a fan of yours as a boxer for
a long time,
but I love how you kind of reinvented
yourself over the last few years.
You know what I mean?
Like you,
like you reinvented yourself with social
media.
Is this something you've always been
doing privately?
You've been talking like this privately,
a hundred percent,
like,
you know,
honestly,
like this is the first time in my life.
I'm 44,
I'll be 45 in December fourth and a few
weeks.
This is the first time I like honestly,
that I've,
I'm really being myself.
I'm,
I'm not putting on a show for anybody.
I'm just showing my real personality,
which I'm silly.
I'm goofy.
I'm sure he said times.
I'm political at times.
I'm a family man.
I'm diverse,
you know,
I love hip hop,
but I don't like listen to rap lyrics.
So I just listened to beats.
So this is who I am and with the,
you know,
with uh,
with thanks to social media,
I'm able to just show it to the world
and,
and that's.
And,
and I let my guard down.
I did.
To be honest with you,
I'm finally being like,
I'm not trying to be a tough guy because
I'm a boxer.
I'm just being who I am.
Well,
it's fun,
man.
You know,
you could tell because there's no other
forum where you would just have a camera
pointed at you.
He just sing mixing smoothies and
talking about organic blueberries.
All the healthy shit you eat.
It's very exciting,
man.
I mean like you'll,
you'll do a video just telling people to
drink water.
And it's true like,
fuck man,
I'm gonna.
Drink some water.
Seriously,
you gotta stay hydrated.
Champion,
you know,
um,
I listen to you as well.
You have a war on sugar,
more sugar and I been out.
I'm totally for that because,
um,
it destroys you,
man.
Destroys every level mentally,
physically.
It just takes away from me.
So I try to step on toes,
you know,
eating right and changing my diet
changed my life.
I was finished.
I was like,
God,
I was a 403 pounds.
I was out of boxing.
I was financially ruined and I'm eating
my,
changing my diet just totally made my
life different.
Well,
I love your story because I,
I love a guy who I love a success story,
but almost more than a success story.
I love a success than fuck your life up
and get it back together again.
So I liked that because there's like
a,
there's a certain amount of enthusiasm
that you have that you,
you,
you know,
that you've seen dark days,
but now you're back,
you know,
and that's part of like the fun of what
you're doing,
you know what I mean?
Thank you.
The sugar thing is a fucked up thing,
isn't it?
Like,
totally because most people don't know.
That's what screwed me up.
I told you I was like,
everyday Donald's and this is after
years of eating right and just letting
myself go.
And that's a whole nother story.
But,
um,
I just fell into a deep depression.
I was just eating junk food all the time
and crispy cream and sugar was just part
of my diet and it was making me crazy
mentally.
I was in cell phone from depression.
I wanted to off myself for over two
years.
I was committing suicide champ.
I was just like,
to the point,
I didn't have a clue what to do,
you know,
um,
although financially I was doing well,
I had got out of box and I had got the
job and,
but I was just,
I had seen so much darkness in my life
from,
from a child and um,
it just,
it was overwhelming because what I did,
Joe was throughout my life,
I would store things and put them in the
closet,
you know,
I was told very young that,
you got to be the man of the house,
you know,
so,
um,
you gotta get over it.
So you're doing that when you're 11
years old,
12 years old,
eight years old.
That becomes your over over time.
I just,
you know,
snapped.
It's too much pressure.
There was just too much pressure.
And then,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a kid,
honestly fighting guys like George
Foreman and Lennox Lewis with very
little amateur experience.
This was all happening fast.
So it just became at a point,
you know,
I got older that was just like,
hold on me.
Well,
when you were young,
you were so hyped up,
you know,
you had this crazy look with the
dreadlocks and Teddy Atlas is behind you
and all these big names and everybody's
like Shannon cannon,
brexit's an expat thing and you know,
you had a lot of success,
but there was some people that felt like
you didn't live up to your full
potential and then you went away for a
little bit and then you came back and
you look better than ever.
This is like,
this is like my third combat,
maybe fourth,
to be honest with you.
This is like my fourth coming back,
so because I've always had like a foot
and boxing,
but it was nothing really.
Something that I was really dedicated to
or had the right team behind me.
It was always something that was to get,
you know,
to get me by to make a living.
And it's finally come to the point now
at 44,
[inaudible] 45.
I think about three,
four years ago when I got to the point
where it's like,
you know what?
I know I'm good at this.
This is something that I've,
I've,
this is a talent that I've had because
I've had one foot in and one foot out
and I've done great.
You know,
they say you can't cheat boxing.
I won the heavyweight title twice,
you know what I'm saying?
Not that I cheated boxing,
but I never,
I never had the stability and the deep
I'm backing,
we're,
I had,
I had a team behind me,
don't get me wrong financially,
but I don't.
I wouldn't say they were for my best
interest in that sense.
Whereas it was a marketing,
you know,
I could,
I could bring in big money from
investors and stuff like that,
but then it got to the point I was like,
you know what,
Shanda,
I'm better than that.
But I wasn't given the opportunity to
have a real training situation.
You know?
I was on my own for a long time.
I really been on my own.
If you look at it since like 1995 when
me and teddy that was split.
I basically been on my own with
different trainers and different
promoters and really no management,
just doing what I had to do to make a
living.
When you look back on your career and
you look back,
especially in the early days when there
was so much hype behind human,
you are the next big thing out of
Brownsville.
You're this guy that everybody was
looking forward to that this is going to
be the next big heavyweight.
How much is that?
Too much pressure in a sense.
In a lot of ways.
Do you almost like not train 100 percent
to give yourself some excuses?
Is that possible?
It's possible.
I guess for other people it wasn't for
me.
What was going on for you back then?
Like what was that like to be that young
up and coming prospect with all those
eyes on them that wasn't really,
um,
it was overwhelming in a sense.
It was fun,
don't get me wrong,
but it was overwhelming in a sense where
it's like,
I knew I wasn't ready.
I had a very limited amateur background
from day one.
I was put on the top level.
I mean,
I had 10 amateur fights.
I was on the USA team.
I fought Felix who had 300 fights when I
had 18 amateur fights on ABC wide world
of sports.
This was a little overwhelming for me.
Not,
I mean 18 amateur fights and here I'm
fighting a guy,
you know,
a gold medalist,
but you know,
it happened.
So I get,
I kinda started out young knowing that
you know what you're going to be on the
big screen,
you're going to be out there,
although you're not prepared.
So you felt like you were always playing
catch up?
Always.
Oh,
until the last couple of years where I
was home making videos,
I had time to get in shape.
I hadn't had a drink in over five years.
I started drinking when I was 13 years
old.
You know what I mean?
I was 13 years old.
I was drinking.
I was homeless from when I was 13 to
about 20 years old.
Live in here,
in here.
So I've been on my own since basically
since I was a kid.
You know what I mean?
So when I was put on an,
on the image,
the top level,
I've always been in a situation where,
uh,
um,
besides playing catch up,
I'm on a Mac,
I'm on the big screen and I'm not ready,
but I got to do the best I can and I've
always done that and that's what I try
to tell people to do the best you can,
you know what I mean?
Do the best you can because you never
know,
but that I'm not ready.
Thing seems to have been the constant
theme.
Like that was always in the back of your
head,
right?
100 percent.
And that was that.
That's confidence.
That's what confidence is.
If you go into any fight saying to him,
I'm already,
you already have to feed it.
And I was so talented that I could still
overcome.
You know,
I fought George Foreman grill basically
on my own.
I wasn't with Daddy.
We had split up.
I met a guy down in,
not a guy,
a friend of mines now and call us up and
we trained for about eight weeks.
And He,
I was battling George George Foreman and
got a close decision,
but,
um,
he,
I was,
I didn't get knocked out and I was happy
with that,
you know,
and I became the linear heavyweight
champion.
I was like,
wow,
you know,
there was a light to beat George
Foreman.
Unimaginable.
There's a mount rushmore of boxing.
It comes to the heavyweight division for
short.
George Foreman's on it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely,
definitely.
Great Guy.
It must have been a trip to just be
looking at them on the other side of the
ring.
Yeah,
it was,
you know,
again,
I wasn't ready,
but I was there,
you know,
it wasn't ready.
Um,
confidence wise,
you know,
I just met the trainer.
We,
you know,
got through to him.
He spoke no English at all.
He would tell me is give me a jump rope
and say jump.
I jumped rope,
you know what I mean?
He spoke no English,
very hard.
Spoke,
spoke very little English.
And um,
I speak very little Spanish but
understood working.
We just worked and I want the title.
Wow.
Yeah.
It was now almost copy on Vamos can't be
all pretty much living in Miami,
you know,
when you,
you split with Teddy Atlas,
that was a big deal too because teddy
atlas is a notorious hard ass now.
I mean he's the hardest of the hard.
I mean even when you look at them,
that big scar across his face and you
know,
he talks very brutally and he was,
he was like open publicly,
like saying that he just didn't think
that you were all in.
That was,
that was,
uh,
that was a real down point in my life
where I really felt like that was one of
the Times where suicide definitely came
into play.
And I know that may sound crazy,
but the reason why is because,
you know,
when I got with Teddy,
I was like 19,
20 years old and he was very over
bearing in that sense where it's like,
you know,
I want to,
I wanted to make it,
you know,
I was homeless,
I wanted to make and I was willing to do
anything he said or without,
with the management said to make it.
Because it was either that or die in
prison.
My Dad was in prison at the time where
he eventually died.
My mom was on drugs.
She was on heroin and crack.
So it was like,
okay,
I got a manager now and I had an
opportunity to a trainer,
Teddy Alice.
We used to train my Mike Tyson.
So I gave myself to him in a sense where
I was like,
everything he says I'm going to do and
in doing so,
um,
I felt like when we split and he
wouldn't publicly and said that about
me,
it hurts so bad because I looked at him
like a father figure because Cedi spent
many days I think,
you know,
tearing me down so he could control and
my mind and that was cool,
you know,
whatever.
I knew I didn't come to him as a kid.
I kept him as a 19,
20 year old.
So when we split and he went publicly,
I was just at a down point.
Everyone,
I was undefeated.
I lost for HBO,
neither the heavyweights,
it was a big,
uh,
you know,
montage about me and everything.
And here I was,
the head of the show and I got knocked
out by Darren Wilson at the,
around and when teddy went out I was
just like,
damn,
you know,
what happened to the days when it was
like me and you were like,
you know,
we,
I was with them for three,
four,
five years from what I'm saying.
It was so much a mental telling me that,
you know,
without me,
you're nothing and you don't have this,
you don't have that.
But then fight time,
you can do it.
So such a mental,
you know,
pumping puppet type of thing.
When we split,
I contemplated committed suicide.
I was in my management's basement.
I had a shotgun.
I was like,
man,
you know,
because I mean I was just in a bad place
and everyone turned it,
turned it back on me.
I mean,
the newspapers rip me apart in his
intelligence influence.
Teddy's influenced with the writers.
And you know,
the New York City cried was such,
so,
so strong.
He had built a great relationship with,
um,
I don't want to put anybody out there,
but he had built great relationships
with a certain certain writers and um,
they just,
everybody's assaulted me.
I was just crazy.
It was one born on Shannon break.
So I survived
that though.
So that was part of me saying,
that's why I tell people I'm the champ
because I've never spoken about this
publicly.
This is my first time.
Let's go champ.
You know,
but uh,
probably hit emotion in my voice,
but I apologize.
But,
you know,
the whole thing is like,
um,
that was,
that was part of the reason why I call
myself the champion.
I mean,
because although when I beat for him in,
you know,
people say,
Oh,
you really lost and nothing.
That third eye I wanted the title that
wasn't winning.
Winning was doing that with my mom had
just died on my birthday,
you know,
that was to me why I'm the champ,
because I went out there with,
you know,
without a stable stability,
stable trainer.
And I still fought and went 12 rounds.
That's why I'm the champ.
Then,
uh,
you know,
those type of moments in my life is yc
and the chain went under title again
with one second left on the clock would
lie Covich.
Um,
that's not why I'm the champ.
No,
because I fought that fight with an
asthma attack and I was born asthmatic.
I meet the fact that I'm even.
Boxing is unreal.
You know,
I spent my childhood in the hospitals.
I got to,
I hardly got an education.
I dropped out of high school in ninth
grade.
Joe.
So,
you know,
I never part of my school,
they used to go on trips,
was to come visit me in school because
of my asthma,
you know what I mean?
So for me to become a heavyweight
champion of the world,
to Tom's about to be three very soon.
This is an accomplishment for not only
myself but for asthmatic and people who
didn't give up because I wanted to give
up.
When Teddy left me,
I want them to give up champ.
Well,
people don't know boxing,
maybe don't know the legend of Teddy
Atlas and him,
how he directly connects the customer on
the early days of the Tyson camp and you
know,
Teddy's a,
he's like a famous motivator,
I would say,
you know,
in a lot of ways,
but I think there's a certain amount of
intoxication that comes from people
telling you you're a great motivator and
you start to believe it and buy it and
do it yourself.
You may remember the Tim Bradley fight,
boys in timberly's caught.
He's like,
we're firemen.
We fight,
they fight the fire.
I love Teddy.
Listen man.
You know,
it's,
it's hard for me and I,
you know,
it's hard for me to talk about this now
because this is before the fame for
teddy,
right?
Like when we met Teddy,
I think he was working in a liquor
store.
I'm not sure,
no disrespect,
but you know,
that's just the facts and he wasn't
doing well financially and my manager
was like,
you know what I spoke about earlier
about he was a guy can go out and raise
capital and he had this young kid from
the same neighborhood is Mike Tyson.
I had just won the national,
excuse me,
the US championships in 92 and 91,
92 and he was able to go out and get in
gods.
He looked back,
my guy,
you know,
like race horse,
you don't just keep it real.
And he got this famous trainer to train
his own race horse was Teddy Alice and I
was,
I submitted.
I was like,
Hey,
whatever.
I was listening,
it was this or jail.
I,
I said dad was in prison and my step dad
was in prison,
was in the streets and the manager was
like,
Hey,
you know what sign would be?
I gonna put your mom in Rehab.
And I was like,
hell yeah.
Okay.
He did everything he said he was gonna
do and he gave.
He believes in teddy and I believed in
and teddy
and the process I watched him say,
he told me I would never be a
commentator because he doesn't feel is
right to talk about fighters.
This is what he told me.
He said he would never be a common ever,
but he,
of course he is a commentator.
This was before he became,
so he decided to become on a lot of
things,
a lot of things that were said.
Um,
basically when we split and he went on
television,
New York one and said,
hey,
you know,
he didn't think I had this in the third.
I was like,
damn,
what will all the times that we were
winning,
it was weak when I lost that one time it
was me.
So,
you know,
I just,
there's not an exact science to
motivating people,
right?
There's not an exact science of training
and a lot of the relationship between a
trainer and a fighter comes to like a
perfect trainer for you might not be a
perfect trainer for another guy.
It's just you gotta have that bond
together and whether you do your don't,
you don't find out until you're in there
right now.
Looking back as a man now as an
accomplished man and you look back on
your days when you were 19 or 20,
what do you think would have been
different?
Like what would you have done to
motivate yourself or to talk to yourself
differently back then?
You know what I'm doing now?
To be honest with you,
I honestly tell you joe,
like what I'm doing right now,
being free.
You know,
everyone's not that type of fighter.
he worked great for I guess certain
people.
I'm not that type of guy.
Look,
I'm a funny guy.
I like to have fun.
I like to laugh.
I like the bug out,
you know?
Um,
I like to live,
you know,
I'm happy.
I'm a happy guy.
Teddy is not different in that way.
You know what I'm saying?
And for a long time I'm look looking.
For example,
Ali Ali trained to archery moy trend.
Another other is before he got the
Dundee.
Dundee knew how to train our lead.
Let him do him and this is what I'm
doing now.
People will say,
you know,
my guys who worked with me,
Jesse Robertson,
Stacy Mckinley,
the great statesman,
Mckenzie,
the Great Jesse Robertson,
these guys know how to train me now and
although I'm 44,
almost 45,
I've learned later on in life how to
just be me be free.
This is,
this works for Shannon Briggs,
win,
lose or draw.
It works for Shannon breeze.
Opposed to being someone else because
someone else said,
and I've done a lot of that.
In the end it became a syndrome where
it's like,
you know,
I grew up,
I grew up in this with a manager,
with a trainer,
and an investor became like a process
for me to go through it over and over
and over again.
It's like to the point where like your
man champ,
do you feel like all these people were
trying to shape you and you were
resisting it or you were confused by it?
I was going along with the program
champ,
you know,
whatever,
survival,
you know,
go on with the program.
The one,
the hardest thing for me and my life was
being homeless,
you know,
being a homeless teenager and losing my
home because it wasn't like something
that I was used to.
I came home from school one day I was
going to pitch a block at school
whenever I came home and we were
affected and I looked through the peep
hole and I looked in.
The apartment was empty and I was like,
I lived here all my life.
I was born and raised in Atlantic
towers,
you know,
so that was a turning point for me.
I,
I left home.
I left that building that day,
a homeless,
the homeless kid and no more comic
books,
no more toys that I grew up,
you know?
And then now the people who
look at me on the gram,
they see my personality,
you know what I'm saying?
They see the comic book side of me.
They see the television side of me.
Whereas I lost my childhood that day
when I went home and we were evicted.
That day became like I had to become a
man that day.
I took the bus to my aunt's house and
you know,
that night she kicked us out so my life
was no longer had a color TV in my room
and you know,
it was all about survival,
you know,
I started getting in trouble and life
took me to where I am now.
Wow.
And you were,
you were boxing at the time to na number
box.
You Start Boxing?
I started boxing.
I was like 16,
17.
So you started boxing as you were
homeless?
Yeah.
Wow.
And how are you doing now?
Like where were you sleeping in
different places?
Sometimes the aunt's house,
a cousin's house or friend's house,
you know,
sometimes the shelter,
uh,
wherever.
I could be honest with you.
And so it wasn't until you started
having some success as a boxer that you
stopped being homeless?
Yeah,
well actually I got an apartment,
my,
uh,
rest in peace.
Jimmy O'farrell my,
my savior,
he found these gems third city when I
was about 16 years old.
And um,
I stopped there many nights too.
I was staying in the gym and that's what
kind of.
Okay.
It was funny because boxing always drew
me back in because,
you know,
I'm like,
I might get in trouble,
go to jail,
get arrested in whatever as a teen and
I'm from wanting to get out of trouble
and had to go to get Jimmy.
Oh,
to hopefully sign for me for probation
or something like that.
And then I'd have to use the gym as my,
uh,
residents.
I sleep in the chair,
man.
It was freezing many nights,
but it's what I had to do until I was
drawn back to boxing,
you know,
I wanted to be.
I always had the talent.
So,
you know,
like for instance,
let me tell you this,
my first guy that ever looked,
gave me some money with shelly finkel.
Wow.
The first guy I was like 17 years old,
18 years old.
He was looking for me.
He was calling around with Gemini,
generally said that Kid's homeless.
It got back to me and he shall,
we think he was looking for me.
I couldn't believe it could show me
think it was shelly.
Thank legendary boxing because after,
and I never forget.
I swear to God,
I went to senior,
I went to see him,
Joe and he gave me five grand.
He was like,
you're gonna make it.
He said,
I want,
you know,
seeing,
what my team or whatever.
I was like,
I can't believe it and I leave this
building I believe is built.
I go to the,
I'm going,
I'm in a train station.
Joe and I take out the money to get a
token.
This is when they had the token booth
and it had to be like 89 90.
And uh,
God's seen me with the money.
I was homeless at the time.
I took trying.
I took out one of the hundreds.
He tried to rob me on the train.
He followed me.
I couldn't believe it.
I had never seen $5,000
let alone I had it in my pocket.
Right.
And I'm thinking this right?
So he tries to rob you on the train pro.
I beat the crap
bottom.
It was crazy.
Jake the wrong dude.
Now when you,
when you went that long period of year
of your life where you're boxing
consistently and then you stopped for
awhile,
what was going on there in your life?
Let me see.
How long did you stop for?
Just one year here.
Two years here.
Three years here.
I was not,
I wasn't consistent.
I wasn't concerned.
I just like,
again,
man,
it goes back to the confidence,
you know,
just never really had the confidence to
really want to do it a to just really
feel like I had a foot of my foot,
my feet solid in the ground and they
miss these last couple of years gave me.
That gave me the opportunity to just,
you know,
train,
stop messing what I call it.
Not that I'm making up for lost time,
but I called making up for lost time
because I'm training everyday nonstop,
you know,
I'll get my rest of course,
but I've dedicated my life for years to
this unit.
And what made you decide to just clean
everything up?
Eat healthy,
stopped drinking.
Like what?
What was it like?
How did you make that decision to just
stop and get it together?
I was suicidal.
I was like,
I had a daughter.
I had my baby girl.
I have two sons.
Chan breads,
my boy.
I love him with death.
Let's go.
Champ is 19.
My son Jaden breaks,
who's 10 years old.
I love them too.
Let's go chat.
And my baby girl chloe and she's uh,
she was,
she changed everything.
She's four now and it was four years
ago.
I got to everything that I always really
everything in four years for the four
years ago,
my life changed,
you know,
she came and she was a spitting image of
my mom and you know,
I was just like,
I was two when she came on,
I could see my mom and I let.
It was like my mom reincarnated.
I'm an only child and you know,
here was,
I was back with my mother again.
I could see it.
It was,
it was an area was a ghost.
And then I was fat.
I was depressed and I was there
everyday.
I sat on the couch where every dime for
one year straight,
like 364 days,
I kid you not.
I Sat,
my wife would get in the morning.
I said,
well,
I would.
I would just give it to my wife to
breastfeed.
I held every day and then it was like
264 days.
I was fat as a balloon.
I'd get up early to get like food.
You don't eat a big bowl of a box of
cereal.
I kid you not.
I put the milk in the fridge.
I put a whole box and a big huge bowl.
My friend called the unger bungalow ball
and I sit there and eat a whole box,
you know,
and I would hold her all day.
And then finally one day I said,
you know what Bro,
you're gonna kill yourself.
And I couldn't imagine her in this
world.
You know what I'm saying?
Having to do things to survive that some
women have to do,
you know what I mean?
And just looking at her and her love for
her.
I got up and I started walking and I
started saying,
let's go chat.
Let's go champ.
You know,
I had no entourage,
no more friends.
My money was gone.
You know,
I had an entourage at one point.
I thought that I thought they jack the
show for me.
I had a,
you know,
I had friends that had cars.
I had a lot of that embedded in that all
disappeared and it was just me and my
baby girl and my family and my wife.
A lot of shout out to my baby.
Let's go champ.
And um,
you know,
it was just a lot of her memories and
anger and I was like,
you know,
I got a,
I got a few lists,
champ.
You got to put this in the right place,
you know,
and I'll shout out to Teddy Alice.
No disrespect.
I got number lot because I learned a lot
from them.
Good and bad.
You're not going to say bad,
but the bad things that I survived,
those things made me who I am today and
that's why I have a family.
That's why I'm able to,
you know,
be here with you today at 45 years old
because I'm strong,
you feel me?
But one thing he told me,
he said,
well,
he told me a long time ago,
1992,
he said,
whatever your fuel is,
whether it's anger,
love,
whatever,
use it.
It may be for some people may say,
oh,
it's wrong because anger pumps
somebody's missing,
you know,
oh,
use positivity,
use what you got to use,
what I'm saying,
do what you gotta do to get what you got
to get.
And there was a lot of hurt and anger
from my pis from that situation,
from other situations,
other management and you know,
I mean I've been through so much
chaplain,
you know,
I was,
I've been heavily involved with some of
the biggest deals and probably this
country's,
this country's history.
I kid you not live nation deal.
I was involved with that.
I mean the first one of the first
reality shows you looking at the
content.
I was involved at the top level of
things,
disappointments,
things not happening where I was heavily
involved in.
I got shocked.
So I was like,
damn,
you know what,
four years ago I was like,
Yo,
you know what,
you've done everything Shannon,
you've done business.
You did well,
you know,
I didn't make money.
I didn't make,
I haven't made much money in boxing.
You know,
I'm around guys like form mean me like
Britney Bowl and a holyfield everyday
guys who'd made hundreds of millions of
dollars.
I'm lucky if I made $4,000,000,
million dollars in Inboxing,
you know what I'm saying?
And the money I made,
I've had um,
it wasn't given to me,
champ,
you know what I'm saying?
I been shot.
I'm gonna.
Keep it real with you.
I've been shy.
So you know,
for me to.
I'm sorry I'm jumping around,
but I learned to use all that,
the field from that anger from getting
shot so many times.
Vernon,
Shannon,
you're not a businessman.
You're a boxer.
Every time you was homeless,
every time he was down and out,
boxing saved you.
You ran back to boxing,
he was doing business.
You made fish.
Made that but boxing.
You know what I'm saying?
Getting,
having peace with that balancing act
like the negative moments that you had
in your life,
not defining you and figuring out how to
use them for fuel.
Figuring out how to look back on those
negative moments and,
and don't,
don't wallow in them,
but say that's never gonna happen again.
That isn't that the great balancing act
of the successful fighter because
there's not a single success for
fighter.
It hasn't come from some kind of
conflict.
Hundred percent.
There's no other way,
but you know,
I think,
I think we do this.
Some of us do this and hopes there is a
finish line.
The finish line is you want to retire
with money.
You want to hopefully leave a name for
yourself,
know what I'm saying and you want to
walk away with and what your brain's
know what I'm saying.
So for me,
I'm trying to leave with my brains.
I'm trying to leave with some money.
You know what I'm saying?
And I'm trying to leave with a name and
I'm using that fuel.
I'm using my past and my present because
I got to tell you the truth,
although I.
There is some past hurt and you can
probably hear them when I talk about
certain things.
There's so much positivity.
There's so much great things that's
happening right now that's surpassing
the.
The,
the,
just the disappointment.
Excuse me,
the disappointment.
So much positivity is happening right
now,
champ.
All around the world.
People saying,
let's go champ.
Yeah,
I couldn't imagine a champ.
I was wanting to commit suicide and now
I'm walking.
Everywhere I go,
people going,
dude.
Got Texts.
Everybody.
When,
when we put on instagram that you were
coming on here.
I got texts from everybody.
Michael Bisping,
UFC,
middleweight champion.
I love that guy,
man.
So many people love you,
You are spreading so much fun and
positive.
That's the real fruit.
Honestly.
Chambliss two tanks.
There's the disappointments and the
hurt,
and then there's the reality that right
now I'm alive.
I survive a bad food.
I survived myself.
Drinking Champ,
champ.
Listen,
at one point Joe,
they had me on Depakote,
seroquel,
Xanax,
Zoloft,
and paxil altogether not together.
Chat for David to me.
Now listen,
I didn't take.
I didn't take the Depakote in circle
because I was like,
come on champ,
you that stuff.
It's like tranquilizers.
Geez.
That's how bad I was trying to slow you
down.
Just trying to kill the champ.
You know what I'm saying?
This big killer and not survive that.
That's why I'm the champ.
That's why I'm the champ because I
survived that.
This overcoming and be like,
you know what?
I lost 160 pounds.
Look at me,
look at me,
look at me champ.
And you're 44,
almost 44,
45 in a week or two and people are
ducking you like crazy.
Interesting.
David said he was all in,
so I'm sorry.
I curse.
I'd probably say curse away.
Let's go chat.
David Haye was all in at one point,
so sorry.
Too many left hooks.
So did.
Yeah.
What happened?
I went over to England,
which I love with my uk.
Had went over there just to fuck with
you got an apartment.
Totally.
Again,
that's the field.
That's the field.
Like honestly,
I was down and now Cham listen.
So many days.
I was like,
man,
you know what?
I'm trying to think,
man,
and no one's giving me a shot and I'm
like,
you know what,
man,
maybe I should get a job and shit.
I'm like,
you know,
you know what?
Then I woke up one day and guess what?
Snoop Dogg said,
let's go champ.
I swear to God he smoked weed.
He's like,
I'm fucking with you.
Let's go channel.
That was the night before.
I was like,
Bro,
the Labor floor.
I was like,
Yo Bro,
you really try and champion have fights
man,
and maybe it's never going to happen for
you.
You know what I mean?
I was like,
Yo.
And then I woke up like four or five in
the morning.
Snoop Dogg was saying,
let's throw a champ.
I said,
I'm back.
That was beautiful,
man.
Well,
you've done some crazy shit too,
man.
Like it was like,
especially with the Klitschkos,
the biscuit.
If I had a lot of fun,
fun videos though,
showing up,
drinking his water,
fucking with him,
knocked him over.
When you were riding the paddleboard
chunk.
Well how long ago was the paddleboard
incident?
And I don't even know.
I can track the time champ.
I was like two years maybe,
but he just,
you couldn't get a fight with him.
Nah,
he saw.
I've been listening.
I've been chasing clicks.
Go honestly,
since like 2005 was supposed to fight
him to fight.
He fought in New York.
City's wasn't fight.
Uh,
Shannon breaks.
Everything was,
you know,
set the goal and he
wind up fighting Calvin Brock,
who's from North Carolina.
No one could.
I couldn't understand where we had,
you know,
we literally had a contract.
Yeah,
it was.
It was going to sell out a lot of fans
with all crazy all the time.
You know what I'm saying?
Because I'm bringing that he didn't want
it because he was dangerous and that's
what I'm going through right now.
They can say what they want about me.
Joe De Sena,
thorough.
He's crazy.
He's this.
But guess what?
I'm dangerous.
I've got tons of emails.
I'm not a snitch.
Listen,
I got tons of emails of guys with their
managers saying,
no,
not right now.
He's too dangerous.
I've got deontay wilder backed out of a
fight with me for $2,000,000.
He can't front.
I got everything.
Let's go chat.
I'm getting excited as you can tell once
you.
Once you started calling him champion to
def con four,
he started calling him the champ.
The meters rosin now.
Now we told you about what?
I want to talk about fights and I still
chat.
Let's go chat.
Let's go champ.
Champ.
And Joe Rogan.
Klitschko one was particularly hilarious
because he was on that paddle board.
There's nothing more humiliating.
They get knocked over.
Still wouldn't fight.
People are talking shit and he still
won't fight me.
He still wouldn't fight me.
Come here.
Look at them.
First of all,
what is he doing out there?
Board by himself.
Stupid.
In the middle of nowhere.
This is almost like a setup Wednesday,
does he?
Yeah,
he does this every Wednesday.
I got mine.
Where does it go?
I'll use it at the coast or somewhere.
Where's that?
Is it Miami?
Fort Lauderdale.
Hollywood champs.
Shout out to Hollywood,
Florida.
Better sound in the world.
Does he live down there?
Yeah,
he lived down there.
I lived down here.
We all live down there,
so he would stay on that power board,
go out in the middle of the ocean.
It'd be pat,
I need this doctor,
and he would just be paddled around this
exercise.
What a weird exercise.
Yeah.
He said,
take a strange guy.
Yeah,
he's weird.
That's how the beef started.
Yo,
Chris,
shout out to Chris Lawrence to have you
with factory.
Who's the greatest guy on earth?
Honestly,
like it wasn't for him.
You know,
this guy put the fuel,
put the cash behind me.
I was flat on my face.
This guy came and was like,
you know why I believe you.
I was fat.
The press.
He seen me in fresh market.
He was like,
you know,
Damn.
I was like,
you know,
he seen me.
I came back like seven or eight months
later I came into his office.
I was like,
Yo,
champ,
what's up?
He was like,
Damn.
He called me and we played.
It was like,
Yo,
we should do something.
I was like,
let's go champ.
And uh,
here we are today.
You know what I'm saying?
I've been traveling world thinks is
Chris and I'm now.
I'm now,
I've actually been ordered the WBA and
ordered a fight between me and Lucas
Brown and hopefully we can make that
happen.
I was seeing something on instagram that
it's,
it's still not signed yet though.
You're disappointed.
Very disappointed.
This is Lucas Brown trying to avoid it.
Or what's time is your,
um,
I want to know what,
you know,
what Joel?
Honestly like I've been through so much
in the last couple of years while we
were quit school with a different funnel
with,
hey this,
I fought haze on the car and I went over
to England,
shout out to the UK.
I love it.
My second home I have a big,
a big fuel injection when I'm doing
right now because I went over there and
I've never felt that type of love
anywhere in the world,
like for myself to go where,
you know,
we speak the same language.
We speak their language and um,
just to have the love man,
it's just incredible.
Everywhere I go,
let's go champ.
You know,
it's just amazing,
man.
I didn't really put a lot into what I'm
doing right now,
but you decided to go over there and get
an apartment.
I had to.
I had to because I was flat on my ass
champ and I was like,
you know,
trying to move up in the rankings.
I gave everybody a call out.
Haman,
every labella,
everybody,
everybody.
The cubist I gave everybody to call was
like,
Yo,
I'm trying to get back in the game.
Nobody believed in me.
Chris Lawrence called me and was like,
Yo,
I believe in you.
And that's what I was like,
you know what Chris?
He said,
Yo,
you a little crazy.
I said,
I am.
I been diagnosed a little crazy.
I suffer from PTSD.
This is true,
you know,
sad.
But um,
what I'm exciting and I'm gonna make it
happen because I'm a believer that
nothing could stop me chatting.
We look at me,
nothing can stop me.
I don't care who you get.
Whoever say they can beat me,
they lying.
Because when we put when the Bell Ring
Champ,
I'm a whole different person because I'm
charged.
Look at me.
Look what I've been through.
Look what I'm telling you.
You can hear the emotion in my voice.
The pain still lit.
Champ.
Let's go champ.
I'm.
I don't understand why it's so hard to
get you fight,
so this is what I'm saying.
Just look at me.
Look at me and I'm crazy.
I believe I'm here.
I'm a promoter.
I don't care who I fight.
They could say what the and then I'm
also not stupid.
I'm not going to fight fights for me,
for guys,
for pennies.
That's meaningless.
That's gonna.
Beat me up.
I'm 44.
I'll be 45.
I already got,
but so much limit on his body.
I'm a heavyweight.
I fought George Foreman Champ.
I fought fatality clinical champ for
free,
by the way.
We'll talk about that later for no
money.
I fought Francoise,
both Ray Mercer.
You feel me in for some big punches.
George Foreman.
So for me,
I'm not going go down.
I'm not going to fight every guy out
there just to try to build myself.
I'm a former two time heavyweight
champion world.
That alone should get me a title fight.
That alone,
that's how it used to be.
Gods have come out of retirement from
the.
From the beginning,
from the Sullivan days and came out of
no,
no fights and got a title fight.
What drives me crazy is your so
marketable.
That's what drives me crazy.
You were in the UFC.
No,
no.
The best ever.
They would be lining up fights for you
left and right.
If you were in the UFC.
Listen,
champ.
I know.
I know that.
That is my boy now.
That's another story in itself.
Nineteen 93 or four.
Maya,
which is his name,
right?
He sold the UFC to Dana and them,
Yeah.
In Two thousand one call rob right now
he tell you who is boy is Shannon
bricks.
He was sitting on the couch with me
waiting for Mark Roberts to come home to
talk,
to try to get mark,
to kick to go in with him with the UFC
champ champ.
Sitting on the couch with a rock or
boxing is hard to get fights lined up
because there's so many different
conflicting promoters and different
piece of the pie
and then it's hard to get fighters to
agree to fight someone like you who's
dangerous?
Dangerous.
I'm,
you know,
I'm fast,
I'm a punch hard and I got a chain so
you know,
they only count on one thing that I run
out of gas and I say this all the time,
champ,
if you'll,
if your biggest asset is hoping on the.
I run out of gas,
you fucked up talking my language.
I apologize.
Boys and girls on apologize.
Messed up.
Excuse me.
I apologize.
Boys and girls,
you messed up if your own.
If you relying on me running out of gas,
that's your.
That's your.
You're going into a fight.
Took my.
Just hope you run out of gas.
You already lost champ.
You already laws now why?
They're worried that you're running out
of gas because I know that you've
concentrated a lot on your cardio in
this.
One of the things you put on your
instagram,
you're always doing cardio.
You constantly doing cardio,
cardio.
If I was born with under the,
under the under developed lungs,
I was born less than two pounds at
birth.
My mom was on heroin when I was born.
Jesus,
so I was.
I was.
I came out.
I came out the womb fighting this.
If I didn't go home for seven,
eight,
nine months before when I was born.
So look at me now.
That's why I'm the Champ Joe.
That's why I'm the champ because if you
can overcome you already to champ,
you had an underdeveloped lungs and
asthma all my life.
You can ask anybody.
I went to school with.
I went to risen Christ Lutheran School
in Brownsville,
Brooklyn for seven years.
Then I went to [inaudible],
then I went to Bishop Loughlin high
school.
Then I went to George wingate where I
got dragged and dropped out.
Now what causes asthma?
Like what exactly?
Like people like me,
we don't have it and you know it's bad,
but you don't know much about it.
What is it?
I don't know.
Chat,
but you know,
looking back like we lived,
you know,
my mom lived in the towers,
but like you know,
my grandma,
my grandma lives on Pennsylvania Avenue
in East New York,
you know,
looking back,
it was an old abandoned building and my
aunt bought from the city for like $7
and they construct.
I'm sure it has the best best to send it
in that type of shit,
you know,
looking back.
But uh,
you know,
I grew up man in the hood,
Cham I grew up in a poor in New York
City,
19 seventies.
I remember everything to black out.
I was on the train by myself.
I was nine years old,
you know,
I grew up hard,
you know what I mean?
So when you get an asthma attack,
is it like.
I was saying that to say asthma is
really in the city and the city's like
that.
It's the comedy in inner city,
Chicago,
La,
New York,
shit like that.
So you think it might be related to
environmental stuff?
One hundred percent now.
What does it feel like when you get an
asthma attack?
US.
The worst thing in the world,
it's like nothing you can ever imagine
because we take for granted because we
take oxygen for granted because it's
just here for us,
but you can go without food and water.
I said all the time for days to weeks,
but you can't go without oxygen for five
minutes with it.
Four minutes,
three minutes,
and that's what I.
that's what it's like.
It's just really,
you're dying.
That's the bottom line.
You're dying.
The friend of mine described it as he
said,
it's like trying to breathe through a
straw.
It's like all of a sudden all you got is
like a little straw.
That's it.
Have you ever had that happen in a
fight?
100 times we'll goes,
whoa,
what's that feeling like?
The worst fear panicking and you started
talking and coming up with things and
believe in doing anything you can do.
You know?
That's was a lot of people in a
religious and a lot of people go to
different things for something outside
of themselves that they can get a hold
onto or ask for help.
For you.
Filming me,
I'm a little different.
I know it's just me.
I got to deal with these lungs and I got
to do what I gotta do to expand them and
what I'm in a fight in that field and he
comes over comm.
So what,
let's go champ.
Now.
When you,
when you have an attack,
is it just take a while before it
relaxes and comes back?
Like what is,
what is the feeling,
man?
I mean,
I know,
I know people take inhalers.
Dilate your lungs.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's a,
it's like being in the water champion
drowning almost.
I guess,
you know what I'm saying?
You're,
you're panicking.
I guess.
You know,
you're suffering,
you're,
you're trying to get that oxygen and.
But,
you know,
it's something that I really,
uh,
thanks to,
you know,
things that I'm doing now,
my diet of first and run.
I really feel like I've overcome it.
So,
um,
the Diet,
cutting out the sugar,
eating really healthy,
no dairy,
no nothing that causes inflammation.
That's made a big information is key.
Inflammation that.
Can you CBD?
Shout out CBDS and management,
these amazing.
Unreal.
Now from doing that,
you uh,
you don't have any asthma attacks
anymore?
No.
Wow,
that's great.
Champ.
I feel like man of steel.
I honestly do.
You know,
I feel like I'm in the best shape of my
life.
Literally.
Have you ever done any breathing
exercises you ever gotten to know?
And it,
it's a hard job because I'm a family
man.
I got no kids and no excuse,
but I found I have a family to take care
of,
provide for and I have a career.
So that's why the things people don't
understand.
Like I've always juggled both.
You don't take care of my family and
myself and a boxing career and it's been
crazy,
but it's been amazing.
Rochap and where I'm at right now.
Oh,
let me tell you a boy joy everywhere I
go.
When did you,
when did,
when did the social media thing kicking
my nephew?
Crack.
Shout out to Craig Brown.
Let's go chat whenever you crack.
Came about four years ago.
Um,
I had my first instagram account.
I was able just photos then.
I was like,
you know what,
man,
I'm going to lose this weight and uh,
it sounds like a corny thing to do and
he was doing like a little blog but I'm
going to just do my own,
you know,
even for myself and I put it up.
I had non followers champ and if go to
like,
you know,
2000.
I was like,
man,
if I could ever get the 5,000
you know,
I'll,
I'll be there.
And um,
I never paid for the followers.
And they went to this whole thing where
they dropped everybody who would pay for
the followers.
I want to be in like $5,000.
I was like,
man,
if I ever get to $10,000.
And then they came up with the video and
Craig came to town,
I was the old crack.
I'm going to work out everyday and I
want you to film it and we're gonna put
it on instagram and see how it goes.
And it just took them off.
But it's just hilarious how much is
taken much time.
Like when I,
when I tell people that you were going
to beyond man,
I'm telling you like,
not like anybody else that's ever been
on.
They got a wave.
He got excited about it.
I appreciate that because they don't
have a publicist,
Chad.
Uh,
I do everything.
We do everything in house jam,
which is just me dragging my family.
We do everything.
We don't have any marketing behind us.
Nothing.
We just out here grinding.
And uh,
fortunately,
uh,
we let the shot now for this web.
Every championship has been ordered as
far as broadening the team.
They'd been delaying.
Um,
I'm not sure if he gon drop out and just
give me the belt.
I'm not sure what's happening,
but if you've been waiting for them to
pull the trigger,
they said they were going to,
you know,
find it,
find and venue and everything that we
talked about.
Australia,
they talked about China.
Who's the promoter?
Uh,
well,
you know,
his,
his management team and his lawyer,
Leon Michael.
Lisa had when,
most of it.
But if they don't come with the deal
champ.
But basically I already feel like
everybody's scared of me,
so I didn't pick you,
just gave me the belt because I just
want to fight clips,
go to be honest with you,
because I want to prove to the world
that he saw in a biscuit because he
really is.
I fought his brother.
Bill went on for 12 rounds,
one on for 12 rounds.
This happened in the first round.
Joe,
he told you about in the first round?
Yeah.
And the first round not only tore the
Bicep,
the tendon popped.
They had to go through both sides.
This was in the first row I took.
I took like unreal punches to the head.
I forgot how many number was,
but I took unreal punches to the head.
They left me for dad.
I ain't even get paid for the fight
champ.
Now what happened there?
How'd you knock your parents?
Listen,
I started,
I started the promotional company called
Golden Empire.
It was basically backdoor,
the change to the empire.
Um,
we fought.
The company felt as though certain
things that were allotted to me.
I don't know.
They said I had a tab.
I don't know,
it's crazy,
but the tide was never produced.
The companies that I started,
basically it wasn't my company anymore
and I was supposed I was supposed to be
given shares.
This company wind up going into try and
trying to purchase EDC,
EDC,
electric,
daisy carnival.
Through my introduction.
You've got crazy.
It went public the night before my
fight,
the stock was up.
I had no shares.
I said,
I'm not signing nothing into.
I know I'm guaranteed a purse.
It was crazy.
Champions would link to my depression.
That's why went home after the fight and
was like,
Yo,
what happened here?
I fought.
I've taught fourth fatality critical for
12 rounds.
I took ass,
man even get paid.
That's crazy.
And that was in court with them for
eight months before I set out on like
pennies on the dollar because I had to
take care of my family champ and it's
what drove me to the pure depression.
But then I overcame that and now I'm
here with you.
How much do they fuck you out?
Oh,
who knows?
Who knows?
I mean the fight,
and let's is facts.
This is champ,
but they like they say in New York facts
and you fell me,
listen,
it was the highest grossing fight as far
as a TV coverage in history at either
one or two in German history.
Shannon braids versus fatality clinical.
He's a huge star in German and I will
see you and I went over there and I
bought action and the people was like,
Yo,
listen,
this guy can sell.
We'd want to see this fight.
The ratings were unreal.
It was like the highest reading in
history,
champ.
I ain't get $1.
That's so not $1 channel.
How can I,
how can I not fall into depression?
But how could I not come out of it?
I've been fighting day one channel fight
the fight,
fighting the brief chat.
So that was the last big bad moment.
That was harsh.
That was back to normal.
Yet she came,
but you came out of it.
Just a beautiful thing about it.
You came out of it.
Yeah,
yeah,
no doubt.
Now at 44,
almost 45 years old,
how much as terrorists?
December fourth,
how much have you had to like alter your
training,
like as you've gotten older,
you've gotten wiser with it?
Because I remember it was something that
Larry Holmes talked about a lot when he
got older.
He's like,
what?
What he did was he was smarter.
He goes,
uh,
I don't,
I'm not trained seven days a week
anymore,
six days a week.
He goes,
I'll train four or five,
and he goes and I won't do three hours.
I'll do an hour and a half,
you know,
and he just,
he still was able to maintain a very
high level by but understanding the
limitations of his body.
Yeah.
Shout out to Larry Holmes,
who's always given me nothing but great
advice.
He's an assassin man,
one of the greatest of all times,
if not the greatest unfortune of being
right after Mohammed.
I was.
People just didn't appreciate them.
I love 100 percent,
but he could definitely get busy.
Oh yeah.
It was a great boxer and he's been
giving me advice since the nineties,
early nineties.
He told me recently,
he said,
don't stop fighting.
He told me,
Whatever you do,
don't stop.
He said,
keep fighting.
I don't care what they tell you,
win,
lose or draw.
You said don't stop fighting.
I was like,
really?
He was.
I'm telling you,
don't fight to the end.
That's what we do.
He said,
if I could've,
I would've stayed fighting to the end.
Well,
I remember when Larry came back when
Mike Tyson went to jail.
He's like,
fuck it,
I'm coming back.
Mike Tyson's locked up and he came back
and a box ray mercer.
And I was like,
wow,
look at Larry man,
just skill and talent that jab.
He had like one of the most underrated
jabs ever bus the bus.
So when you are now a 44 years age,
you're,
you're healthier than ever before.
You take care of yourself better than
ever before you look fantastic.
Have you,
have you altered your training at all?
Like what have you done to make sure
that everything is,
uh,
you know,
going smooth?
Yeah.
When I first came back I was,
oh Dan,
of course I was again trying to make up
for lost time.
So I was training everyday,
everyday and injuries would just come in
here and get Kiwis.
This one,
not one elbow,
just going to hard.
That was going to hard.
Then I met Dr Buck and whole foods one
day.
Shout out to Dr Buck.
And he was like,
who's Dr?
Buck,
he's a,
he's a nice guy,
man.
He's what is he a Chinese doctor
tightening Chinese medicine doctor.
And he gave me a great plan and he was
like,
you know,
champ,
you should train three days,
take a day off,
training two days,
take two days off,
train four days,
take three days.
So.
And I was like,
wow.
He was like,
trust me,
it wasn't work for you.
He was like,
the body beats rest.
And I started doing that.
Chairman has been working for me.
Great.
I feel better than I've honestly.
I've never felt this strong.
I've just bought that day for yesterday.
Shout out to Trevor Brian.
I've been coming to heavyweight.
Uh,
it gives me great work for him.
I'm,
I'm where I'm at,
thanks to him.
He's been training me for the last three
years.
I've been watching the train sparring.
We spoke the other day.
I'm going to get you because he put me
in the eye by the way,
but I'm still pretty.
Let's go chat and um,
you know,
I've been training.
I've been sporing I'm the fastest I've
ever been.
I'm stronger than I've ever been.
I see everything.
You know what I mean?
In the room when I was young men again,
I was battling with.
I'm not supposed to be here right now.
How many?
Like,
you're not supposed to be here.
You're not supposed to be here.
You know what I'm saying?
Y'All feel good.
Chair.
I get it,
I get it.
But it's all about getting yourself
prepared for the moment where you could
perform.
And I think so many guys leave too much
in the gym because they have this thing
in their head that you can't do too much
trade smarter,
not harder.
That is it.
Right?
And it's a balancing act smarter,
not harder.
Trying to find that balance between the,
the car.
You don't want to sell yourself short.
You don't want to not push hard enough
to,
to reach your potential.
But how do you figure out like when,
when you're in,
when you're out,
how do you feel,
how do you figure out how to reach that
perfect potential?
Because only,
you know,
I was working with a guy I love him,
shout out to billy and billy told me,
he said,
you know what,
you got to once in a while,
push yourself to see how far you can go.
He said,
you know,
you could run 15 miles,
but can you run 20?
I was like,
damn,
you know,
so once in a while I do give myself
that,
you know,
what,
what can you do?
I'm going to try to make A.
I'm going to try to make it up and down
these stairs.
Know 100 times,
you know what I mean?
I'm going to do the best I can just once
in a blue and then I give it.
You know what?
I may do that again in three months,
two months.
You know what you gotta know your body
to channel.
You got honest and you got to be honest
with yourself.
Because I wasn't always honest with
myself because of asthma,
I was having high anxiety when it came
to running and they came to like pushing
my lungs because this is something I've
experienced all my life since birth.
I don't,
I can't remember,
you know,
finishing school because I was always in
the hospital.
I grew up in St Mary's in Brooklyn.
St John's in Brooklyn,
kings county in Brooklyn.
I grew up in the hospital.
I can tell you what the children's play
rooms look like.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm a kid,
kids ward.
So I grew up in these places,
so for me to become a box and have to
use so much breathing,
it's amazing.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm not trying to get myself a blow job,
but it's just the truth.
You know what I mean?
It's not.
No.
I mean,
what other heavyweight champion history
can honestly say they suffer from
something.
We're underdeveloped lungs and became a
champion and him on the greatest
champion.
Hell no,
but could I be possibly.
Because if I had the lungs that some of
these guys had,
who knows how good I might be a fast.
I hit hard.
I'm crazy.
I'm with whatever.
Whatever,
champ.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm Joe.
They haven't seen the best to me to be
honest with you.
They've never seen the best and no one
has and I.
and that's why I'm back because why?
Like I don't want to leave this earth or
wherever I'm going next level,
the next dimension.
I didn't want to go st man.
I wish they had seen me because I'm nice
Joe.
Honestly,
those who really know me,
like I'm really good at this box and
things like I'm self taught.
I watched Mohammad Ali and Ray Robertson
till I was blue in the face as a kid and
I eliminate them as a heavyweight.
You got one of the best left hook to the
liver.
Chavez Vamos to be on.
Oh,
there you go.
Let's go.
Go,
go.
Mass part of this coming back.
My brother.
Yeah,
that's definitely.
It's a stabbing left to guys around.
I snatch it,
but shout out to us,
you know,
you know black people would shout out
McCallum McCallum.
I got that from him.
Oh yeah.
I met Mike when I was 18 years old in
prospect park.
Oh Wow.
I remember when he knocked out Donald
Curry.
I was a huge Donald Curry fan.
I got so depressed I had to go running.
I,
I shut the TV off.
I was like,
fuck.
And went right.
He hit him with a left hook to the body
and went upstairs,
went boom,
knocked him out cold.
I had to go running.
I ran and I said to myself,
I'm never going to get depressed at
somebody else's last ever again.
I was,
I was a kid.
I was so bummed out.
I was like huge Donald Curry Fan.
Mike taught me that hat,
but I watched.
I watched the vest so much done.
I just feel like if we're going,
I've got to put effective.
I get you there.
You could call it good night.
It might catch up to you later though.
It might be chilling for a minute round
next time around.
You be like,
Oh shit.
Gotcha.
Let's go chop now.
Do you follow a strength and
conditioning program?
Do you have a trainer that you work with
for strength and conditioning?
I work with different guys.
What kind of Shit do you do?
All type of shit.
Chad,
you name it.
I've.
I've been doing this for years.
I worked with Mackie show stone chat.
Oh,
days before this was popular.
I mean he was back.
He worked with spinks,
so get me wrong,
but I worked with stone.
I've worked with God.
This ain't nothing new to the chair.
You feel me?
Well,
she'll stone was the first guy that
really became prominent as a strength
conditioning coach.
I was with the great time.
Short time shows.
Demand.
Yeah.
I worked with Duke Roofs,
man.
You don't do groups.
I know the name rules.
I work with Duke rules out of New
Orleans.
He's the best in the world.
Rod Gillis,
I worked with everybody.
Chimp and Maggie.
She'll stone was the guy that pumped a
spinks up when he fought Lara.
He bumped them up a little bit,
but it didn't slow him down.
That's right.
He had this boy,
didn't you work with Holyfield too?
He worked with Holyfield as well.
I think he worked for Hany leaning.
Oh,
okay.
He might've worked with holy,
holy is the man holy.
He worked with everybody to holy was the
real guy who bought this.
Bought that into prominence as far as
strength and conditioning and and
especially in boxing.
You know what I mean?
This was the first one of the first guys
were weightlifting became accepted
because for the longest time boxing
trainers will tell you that weight
lifting slows you down,
which it kind of does because it makes
you soar and then you don't perform as
well in the gym,
but once you recover then you're fast
again.
So holyfield was like one of the first
guys to make that leap,
to understand like,
look,
he's going to go from a cruiserweight to
a heavyweight and he became a legit
heavyweight.
One of the best ever.
I mean his performance against Mike
Tyson.
Come on,
man.
I want him in both him and dope.
Come on man.
You ain't see me and him moving the
other day.
Me and wholly,
he's still got it.
He still do something,
but he got it because he's still
fighting.
No,
he ain't fighting.
He stopped now,
but he's still got to champion.
I was moving with another day.
Wow.
He's still got it.
Still bold.
Really Bold in the gym with me every
day.
Really?
Every day.
You live in Florida.
He's a great guy.
Killed him for this.
He is.
Wow.
So he still trains all the time.
Everyday.
How come he doesn't fight anymore?
He chilling.
He like Yo just said enough is enough.
You good job.
Wow.
So when you work with a strength and
conditioning coach,
like what is like a week in the life of
Shannon Briggs when it comes to
training?
Like say if this fight gets signed and
you know you're going to get started,
how do you organize your weeks already
started,
but what I'm,
what I'm doing is basically I'm using a,
a strength and conditioning day with
boxing.
I running day with boxing a rest day.
A strength and condition.
They would,
you know,
with boxing day and then another run
day.
You ever fuck with yoga the best?
Yes.
They understand you and Christina is
great.
Yeah.
So you got all kinds of stuff going on.
Flexibility.
I'm doing everything I can do.
Possibly.
Um,
cryo machine.
you named a hyperbaric chamber.
Everything I could do,
I'm looking for the edge because
everyone wants that.
They get,
they got a champ.
I'm,
I'm broke.
They got money.
They.
So imagine what they got it.
Now I'm scrambling to get everything I
could get.
You know what I mean?
To get to the next level.
I know,
I see it,
I see it.
Any man and I'm me,
like many other people rooting for you.
Thank you,
chair.
Just it's frustrating when I see you
getting close to these fights with guys
like David head and then it falls apart.
Sucker.
What happened when they said he was
going to fight you?
I went over to England champion.
They showed me nothing but love.
They seen the true character of who he
really is and that he ain't really a
good dude,
man.
He's not,
he's a businessman,
but he's also like a,
you know,
he's a,
he's a weird dude,
man.
You know what I mean?
Y'All shook his hand.
We said we had to go because be
grateful.
Great.
Fight,
win,
lose or draw for either one of us.
Um,
and everything was set and he,
I did everything they needed me to do
and then he just,
uh,
he felt he was looking for another deal.
And the truth of the matter is,
I heard this from inside that he was
like,
it's too dangerous,
you know,
that's just the bottom line,
which is what they all.
He's a fairly small heavyweight.
Y'All smash them up.
That was easy one for me.
That was a layup.
I was like,
oh,
look at him on bumble,
smashed.
And he was scared.
A little steam in his eyes.
I'm from Brownsville.
I got one thing I could smell when you,
when you're scared.
I'm from the same neighborhood as Mike
Tyson.
Ready?
Paul?
I know when a man scared.
I went up on him.
Joe.
I looked in his eyes.
I seen his lips.
He was trembling.
He was scared.
I could smell it.
I was like,
oh,
this is a layup layup champ.
This is an easy one.
Champ.
Yeah.
What does he wait?
He's not a.
it's not a heavy guy.
I had that one child.
I could see me just snatching them.
You went Vegan?
I'm eating bowls and cows and dinosaurs.
Straight animal.
What is your diet like?
Like what?
How do you organize your diet?
Everything.
You know what I'm saying?
Just to try to,
you know,
if it's whole foods,
I can't buy it.
They love.
They know me well,
you know what I'm saying?
You know they should be sponsored.
Me Shout out to whole foods.
I'm,
I'm there everyday.
It's a 150 to $200 a day for the final.
Yes.
Every day.
For the last four years we've been
eating from old food stamps are not
cheap.
One 50 to 200 every day of his bed.
And normally I'm not bragging.
I'm actually complaining because.
But that's what it took because I'm no
sugar.
I'm eating right.
I use coconut sugar,
you know what I'm saying?
I just tried to do the best I can
consider.
I don't,
I'm not a nutritionist.
Uh,
I live on my iphone as you can tell
them,
always posted and I'm always looking for
new recipes or new,
the next edge,
what's,
you know,
what I'm saying?
The Best I can for myself.
So I eat,
I eat,
I eat fairly well.
Organic meats.
I don't eat pork.
I'm on each.
I don't eat shell fish,
no dairy,
you know what I mean?
I'm just keeping it as best I can.
Do you get your blood work monitor to do
that as well?
Yeah.
You know,
I try to keep my levels where they need
to be.
Do you supplement a Tta?
Unfortunately,
no,
not right now.
No,
Some CBD that,
um,
I've been,
you know,
and I was ahead of me ahead of the game
with that to chairman.
I'm not trying to get myself a blow job,
but I was suffering from depression
champ and I was fortunate to uh,
I went and got like 10 different Mris
and I was like,
what's wrong with me?
I'm always depressed.
I'm always feeling like,
you know,
I'm,
I feel anxiety overcoming me and I was
given this night and then I was hip to
cbd for a few years ago,
four years ago,
and changed life,
changing experimentation.
I mean,
but I'm here,
I'm here.
But CBD is an interesting thing because
a,
it's a part of marijuana but it's not
psychoactive.
So a lot of people like they,
they hear about it and they get worried
about it.
They feel like it's drugs.
Yes.
But it has nothing to do with that.
It's like one of the beneficial parts of
the plant just eliminates inflammation
and for people that have arthritis or
all kinds of other injuries or just hard
training like you're doing.
And I was drinking since I was,
I was a kid,
you know what I mean?
Honestly.
And I had a,
I had a,
I had a family member that,
that was an oh,
marijuana smoke and we're kinda was.
The person was abusive to me,
very abusive physically and mentally.
And um,
so the smell of marijuana was something
that always reminded me of those times
as a child.
So,
you know what I mean,
growing up.
So I never was attracted to motor we
ever,
but drinking was my king,
which was worse and I was drinking since
I was a kid and I've shouldn't have been
in.
Just led me down some dark days when you
drink it during training camps.
I'm not really,
I wasn't never that type of drinkable
after a fight,
you know,
celebration,
Heineken,
Heineken and Hennessy was chasing and
just being,
you know,
a kid,
not a kid being an idiot.
And how'd you get off it?
Um,
my daughter man,
you know,
adopt my daughter,
I was taking,
like I said,
I was taken um,
the different antidepressants and they
gave me Xanax as well.
And my mom was a heroin addict.
I told you crack and she died on my
birthday of overdose.
And I said if I was ever hooked on
drugs,
I'd rather die.
And you know what I'm saying,
be a slave.
I hooked or something.
I remember not taking the Xanax for a
couple days and just having like the
jitters and almost like,
Yo,
this is horrible.
When that happened,
that went on for like six months and I
was blessed and when I was introducing
cbd because my life changed,
I went from not knowing what I was going
to do when fearful to you're calming
down and this was all from my past.
So many things that happened to me as a
kid I don't need to harp on,
but my childhood was rough and people
don't realize how much keith internalize
and become adults are bad.
Broken kid is a worse adult forms.
Yeah.
Forms.
And when I got money champ,
I was 20 years old.
My manager,
you know,
move me out to jersey.
I was living in west,
south,
west orange,
big mansion,
you know what I'm saying?
Always living in a nice house and of the
car it was,
but I had no work,
no money,
but I had the things that,
you know what I'm saying to me,
I made it.
I had a care credit card,
you get close.
I want to do is fight.
So I had a nice thing going,
but I wasn't really dealing with the
fact that my mom was on drugs.
My Dad was in jail.
You know what I'm saying?
I was born that piece.
I wasn't nowhere near piece I didn't
know and that's what yoga has done for
me.
Yoga has done that for the people that
know.
They see the crazy side of me.
Like I'm like the spiritual crazy
warrior.
Don't even say spiritual because I'm not
even a spirit.
I'm just like the crazy warrior,
but I get centered when I have to and
that's what I'm learning.
Like I never knew how to turn on the
Lesko champ.
I tell everyone,
listen,
there is a champion with all over people
see me hype.
How I go from.
That's me turning on the champ,
champ.
That's me turning on the champ because I
didn't know how to do that.
That's why I say I'm in the best shape
ever because now I can zone out.
I was on my way over here,
champ in the car.
I was like,
Damn.
Oh nervous.
Let me tell you why.
When I was fat and depressed and down
and out,
I was watching you and I said,
damn,
I need to get my shit together and to do
that one day I'll be on Joe Rogan's
show.
I'm not bullshitting you.
Anybody can say whatever they want to
say.
I'm seeking God's with you.
So on the way over here I was nervous,
but I was like,
let's go chat.
No need to be nervous.
You know?
What are the things I love about
youtube?
Like you,
you push that positivity on other people
and you want them to be positive too.
It's not just about,
you know,
like you call everybody champ.
Everybody's a champion.
They're all smiling.
You'll hear your videos.
That's real.
That's.
I'm happy man,
because I'm happy to be alive.
Job wanting to.
I wanted to kill myself.
So many kids commit suicide around the
world.
Champion.
I've got thousands of emails and texts.
Kid you not,
I can show you my phone.
Thousands of emails and text with people
around the world.
Champ.
I was suffering from depression and I
wanted to kill myself,
but thanks to you watching the videos,
I'm motivated and I'm like,
but my bs in thousands,
over 15,000
of people telling me,
champ,
thank you.
Thank you.
So this is for me.
It's amazing.
No publicist,
no company behind me.
This is just me and Craig.
That's all you need though.
Know what I'm saying?
You feel me?
But that's why I feel good because I'm
like,
damn,
if this was not real organic,
I'd be like,
okay.
I could be like,
ah,
you know,
but this is just
real.
It's not like a marketing mind and this.
I'm either going to win,
lose or draw and they ain't gonna be no
losing being who I'm going to be for
once in my life.
Well that's the beautiful thing about
social media is that it lets you be you
100 percent.
Like there's no director goes.
Yeah,
there's no direct on Shannon.
I see what you're saying right now.
I want to want something different from
chance.
Right,
right,
right.
I'm sticking.
I tell people when it comes to that,
people say,
oh,
it's boring.
You know you do the same thing on
Thomas.
He says,
meet me.
I'm like,
you know what is as you watched it too
much.
Come back later.
They come back later to tell people that
about my podcast.
You know,
man,
I'm tired of listening to you could take
some time off.
I get tired of me too.
Let's go chat.
Jason.
Changing Shit.
Ministerials good man.
For Real.
I needed to vent to which we can hear.
You know what?
I needed to vent a little bit about the
alice thing and not that.
You know what I mean?
It,
I held it in all this time because this
feel.
I'm sure I'm gonna lie,
you know,
I watched him many days.
I said,
damn man,
like,
you know why he threw me under the bus
like that and you know what I mean?
Hurt.
So now he's a hard man.
I got a huge article coming out for espn
by brand Johnathan Butler.
It's unreal.
I looked for him to do this piece.
He's the guy who's done like,
he's done some amazing pieces.
Champ,
Mike Tyson,
Tupac.
He saw some amazing pieces.
He's got a piece coming out that's going
to be into the Monitor,
but not that I'm plugging him.
I just want you to know this is going to
be unreal.
Beautiful.
It's going to be on ESPN.
ESPN.
It's going to be.
That's giant,
but there's a lot of momentum in your
side.
It's just a matter of getting a fight
sign.
You don't have.
The heavyweight division right now is
pretty exciting.
It's not in the face.
Done the big,
the fights done.
I'm just saying for,
for Brown,
those people to to act like they had.
They were going to grab the bull by the
Horn and not be able to come up with a
deal.
You know they had.
I think they have a couple of days until
we go to bed.
Like if that was the case that we should
have just went to perse.
But I'm ready now.
What I'm saying.
I'm ready now.
I don't want no more delays.
I don't want to play with this boy.
Another boy.
Don't want to pay with this man,
this young man with a family.
I don't want to play with him.
I want the bell will ring because he and
my way.
I understand,
but he's in my way and there's nothing
like people don't want to stand like you
can call me crazy.
But that's,
that's okay.
Look,
my mind and my mind.
This is like a already written destiny.
I was a lot of shape.
I was dealt and now I wanted to kill
myself and now I came back with nothing
behind me.
But the people,
the people's chairs,
everywhere I go,
he's in my way.
He's just like a tornado come and he's a
role.
I'm a temporal part.
He just said my wait,
because I got a bigger picture champ.
All the belts I want to.
People around the world,
all the belts,
chaps.
I want people all around the world and
be like,
Yo,
hear my story.
I got to.
I don't have a great record.
I've got like six or seven point five,
six lawyers.
Who knows.
Um,
I had ups and downs.
I've never been considered a great,
but I fought guys who will tell you on
the low man.
He kept busy.
Excellent.
It's Louis.
They'll tell you guys who,
who,
who know me or who,
who box acts,
Chris Bird.
They say,
you know what Shit and never read that.
Never really seen Shannon.
They never really seen Shannon.
I'm honest.
I'm.
I'm keeping it real.
They never seen me.
They going to see me win this fight.
Get done.
They're going to see me.
They going to see the real shit.
They're going to say,
wow,
we didn't know yet.
All that talent we didn't know.
Let's go chap chap stick won't see it
for real.
This is a lot of suffering.
Pain Champ and a lot of love too because
they're all around the world.
They say,
unless champion,
they fill in the positivity and they
said,
you know what jam we behind you man.
The people,
sure that's not happening in boxing
champ and that's and that and that is
another reason that's fueling me to look
at the box and look at a state of the
heavyweight division.
It was flat before me,
champ.
Crypto was doing nothing but sticking up
division for kids.
Grab whole,
grab,
hold.
Come on.
Champion heavyweight champion of the
world.
You're supposed to be the biggest
project.
Sports.
You're supposed to be out there doing
interviews.
You're supposed to be Muhammad Ali,
you to stay around people's around kids
around the world.
Supposed to know her head,
which had been the world when I was out
there trying to campaign and even to
this day,
you ask somebody who's the heavyweight
champion and rural.
They don't even know.
Nobody knows.
Nobody knows now.
And he was a white guy.
Yeah,
but ask them now.
They don't even know.
Nobody knows.
Now you go around and keep people.
Call me one thing,
champ.
Yeah,
they say chat when you're fighting.
Exactly.
So that's what I.
that's what I'm talking about.
Bringing back the imagery to the game.
Listen,
people told me all the time,
the people in the game,
but I hear people you know,
ride you.
I see one of the uncommons ride me to
you and it started thorough and I
appreciate your chair for holding me
down,
but listen to this champion.
Listen to this chap,
the people inside of boxing is one
thing.
Inside of contact.
Sports is one thing,
but when you got people who don't watch
boxing,
who don't never watch box and said,
hey champ,
I watched your champion.
It's social media,
it's social media.
You feel me?
That's what's doing it.
So that's my goal.
That's my point.
The boxing people who.
Not that I don't want them to know me,
I'm not trying to alienate them and say,
oh no,
fuck them.
I'm saying,
that's cool.
I love y'all.
Oh,
you don't like me.
I know I suck.
I'm missing a door.
But the outside people all around the
world who don't watch boxing the ladies
to kids.
It's the champ.
Shannon,
the candidate who I want.
I want this.
I guess what I have right now.
Kids everywhere.
I came out of a place the other day and
a kid I know he wasn't a boxing fan.
He said,
hey champ.
I said,
wow.
I felt good champ.
I felt good bro.
I was like,
that was like a weed.
He's moment.
I felt like the readings moment,
like,
hey champ,
you know what?
I'm saying that's what I want,
man.
I want people to be excited about
bicycles.
Boxing saved my life.
Every time I left the game chat,
my life fell down,
but there was a long period of time or
Klitschko was a heavyweight champion
where literally no one could tell you
outside of real hardcore boxing fans who
the heavyweight champ was here in
America right here was never the case.
You would ask people who's the
heavyweight champion and they would
have,
oh,
it's Mike Tyson,
it's Lennox Lewis,
evander Holyfield,
whoever it was,
but for a long period,
no one cared.
It was just a such a boring style.
He didn't want.
He didn't want to mix it up and put her
in line.
He was more concerned with his legacy
gas plant is safe.
And you know what I mean?
I,
I think it's like you look at wrestling
or even like in the mail,
like you guys come back,
you guys fight and you lose.
Okay,
you come back,
you fight again.
There's no set.
Schedule One with these guys with
boxing.
Um,
and then guys don't want to lose.
You don't.
And then they fight in God,
they fight what I call pies,
you know,
they call it fighting pies just to stack
up.
They wreck it remains.
So they got great records and we all do
it.
You got to patch.
This is the game.
Unfortunately it's the game.
But if you were telling me,
look,
you can fight,
you can fight and win,
lose or draw your guaranteed going to
fight another fight for $3,000,000.
You'd fight this guy all the time.
But what happens when you lose?
And then you go back to making $500 a
fight,
$5,000
a fight.
So guys don't want to lose,
right?
It's just part of the game in boxing the
record,
the winning record is so much more
important than this than MMA fights in
mma.
It's just about a p and exciting,
right?
I had some losses.
Nobody gives a shit.
You know?
I was K one,
right?
Yeah.
A kid.
What was that like getting the worst
thing ever.
Who did you fight?
A Erik Erickson.
Tom,
Eric,
Tom Erickson.
I kicked the shit out of each child.
I think I'm the first guy ever to scream
and the history.
Did you train it all leg kicks in?
I did.
And um,
it was shit.
It was for nothing because he kicked the
hell out of me.
He's a big fellow,
a man.
I couldn't believe it felt like it.
Something like two bats it together.
I said if he kicked me one more time,
I got to go down.
I can't take it.
I don't care,
you know?
I said I can't take it if he want more.
He kicked me again.
Like I said,
I said I got.
I jabbed into the body,
boof.
And when I,
and he looked at me because I'm able to
read fast,
you got to be able to read within tenths
of a second milliseconds and boxing.
I read in his eyes that that wasn't that
bad.
Like he must've felt like it wasn't that
strong of a punch and he could come and
he came in to punch at that point and
when he came into punch,
I just,
I,
I let,
I let the candy go.
I left,
right go freedom champ.
Got Them on top of the Hash.
Sheesh.
God,
I get excited because I know the feeling
now tapped in all these years I was
playing with the game.
Now I finally tapped in because I've
focused and concentrated on just doing
this,
that now I know how to put it there.
I know how.
This is my gift.
This has been my gift.
I've had a rough life,
but my gift is that I have a talent in
something that I've always kind of ran
from if I had my own reasons,
but now I've got it.
I've channeling,
I've channeled this shit kind of thing.
Come about,
man.
Herman Triseto.
Shout out to Herman.
He,
um,
you know,
me,
me and the hustle,
me and a struggle with trying to make
some bread.
Man.
I'm a businessman.
You know,
I'm,
I'm a working man,
not a businessman.
I'm a working man and it's work.
You know what I mean?
If,
if that was going to fight in the UFC,
I came out to Vegas Champ Out Dana,
put me up at the,
um,
Dana put me up at the palm or somewhere,
a mg.
He put me up in the suite.
He was talking about me fighting.
What's my boy name?
The big white dude back in the days,
I want to say around 2005.
Six.
Uh,
randy coture.
No,
no big tall,
tall,
white dude.
Tim.
Sylvia.
No.
Give me one of truth.
Was he how highly ranked was the guy?
He was the one.
He became the champ.
Okay.
He wanted me to fight them.
They put me at.
Flew me in,
put me in Dana Nomi.
Well,
Tim Silvia.
Silvia.
Was it?
That was before Tim Silvia.
Probably.
There's a toll dude.
Real toll after other tims.
So tall white dude.
He wanted to fight in Tim Silvia Fault
Ray Mercer and Dr with one punch.
He fought,
right?
Oh,
okay.
That's him.
Wait a minute.
Ray Mercer also far merchant and beat
him.
No.
Kimbo slice and Kimbo a guillotine.
Dm.
And then ray mercer,
Tim Silvia.
And it was supposed to be a boxing
match,
but the athletic commission wouldn't
sanction it for boxing match because Tim
Silvia didn't have any boxing matches.
I have to see this picture though,
if I see a picture of you tall and his
skin was hanging down like how long he
can share a landscape was eco box
though.
The kid he could box.
He had some good shit though with his
hands.
He,
I don't know if his name but dude could
get busy.
I was going to fight.
He asked me to fight him.
We were like,
look,
100 was negotiated for me again.
He was like,
Yo,
uh,
give us somebody a little easier because
they wanted me to fight.
Um,
what's his name now?
Mark Hunt the black brother.
What's his name over?
He was fighting k one for awhile.
He fought.
You have say to UFC to carry goodrich
goodrich.
Let's go big daddy.
They wouldn't be the fight.
Good rich chapter chair.
I've been in the game chat.
So did you.
Did you take any wrestling classes or
anything?
Listen,
Yo kid,
you weren't ready for this.
You ready for this?
I'm ready.
Let's go.
Champ.
American top team La.
That's how.
That's my boy.
That's my boy man.
Dan Is my homie.
He was there when they were in a store
front and Boca.
No,
Jim a store front in Boca.
I went down there because they wanted me
to teach them how some teachers,
some teachers teach them boxing.
That was like 2001.
Why?
And um,
I started messing with dom and I was
doing some mom take wine dough and I was
doing mma,
Jujitsu and all that.
And it was kicking my ass,
but I was loving.
I was getting strong.
I was like,
Yo,
this might be a great type of thing that
costs up with the box and that's what
I'm in the clenches,
you know what I'm saying?
Oh yeah.
Big Difference in the clenches right,
man,
that's why I.
Sprint planning is important.
Yeah.
It's important for boxes now and these
days.
So what happened?
How come you never wound up doing an MMA
fight?
Um,
besides not wanting to get my ass
kicked.
Oh,
you know,
just so hard on the body.
Hard,
brutal,
brutal.
Brutal.
Wrote joints,
the NAC,
it'd be like me playing basketball.
I can't dribble.
I'm like,
the only black man in the world can
dribble a basketball.
I can't catch a football,
you know?
Wow.
So
you just decided it's just not for you
so bad.
I pay one experience,
man.
I tell you,
I was like,
man,
I just.
You know what's funny?
Because I went,
I went back to the hotel and I was
chilling.
I was laying in bed and um,
I went to sleep.
I just had a little couple of bruises
and when I woke up my entire both legs
were black and blue.
I was like,
I painted.
Oh snap.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Yo,
just get me Outta here.
They paid me.
Well Chad,
I might've made like in over two years I
made.
I made a good chunk of change over
there.
I went to the irs chasing me down.
I don't got no bread.
There was fun.
It was fun.
Let's go chat.
So you decided one and done with
Katelyn?
Yeah.
Katelyn wasn't the thing for me.
And um,
but I love it,
I love watching it and I think that
training was tremendous for me.
I was in general that they was saying
tyrone sponge,
that's the chat for real motherfucker,
y'all.
He's the man for real.
Let's go champ.
He says,
man,
help me out with my kickboxing because I
think it's definitely helped my boxer.
Yeah,
he sent in the borderline.
He's been doing a lot of boxing matches
and not exactly sure if he's going back
to kickboxing,
he'll fight anybody anywhere.
Anytime though I'm just waiting for the
right contract or anything.
He'll beats beats.
He's very talented.
He's a very smart dude too.
He's on the ball.
Yeah,
I'm going gonna be working with him for
this fight as well.
Oh beautiful.
So when,
so you said we're very close to purse
bits.
So it's happening 100 percent.
Whether this guy is in or not.
They gave me,
they gave me the bell in a box.
I'll take it.
I'd rather winning in the ring,
but I'm,
you know,
I'm,
I'm frustrated.
I ain't gonna lie to each other.
I'm very frustrated.
I'm trying to be happy about,
you know,
my situation because I am getting in a
fight,
but again,
I'm the politics of boxing with ups and
downs,
these,
these managers or shift DNA saying one
thing and they're telling me to wait.
I don't know why I say the whole thing
with me is like,
like what happened with,
hey,
it's happened to me so many times.
I live in fear that I'm going to get
shocked.
Like,
okay,
what,
what they gonna shock me with now
because if they're delaying,
so what's next?
You know what mean I'm expecting
something if nothing happens,
I'm hoping for the best,
but I'm ready.
It's gotta be a weird situation field.
Right?
It's all good champ.
I'm the champion.
This is what they got to do to try to
keep me down.
What the heavyweight division right now
is exciting though.
Now there's a lot champ.
Yeah,
that's a big part of it.
Yeah.
There's a lot of good stuff happening,
right?
Yeah.
And what did you think about Ortiz's
fight the other night?
Uh,
it was,
it was shocking that he went to the
distance,
right?
No,
not at all.
Because he fought Malique Scott,
who was the guy who was in tip top
shape.
We get an instagram always trading,
always training.
Very,
very defensive,
which is hard to beat a guy like that.
It's hard and I got a guy who don't want
to get knocked out.
Chat.
They filmed me.
I'm not getting knocked out.
He gonna do whatever he can.
Not to get knocked out.
Doesn't mean he gonna fight back and let
me see.
You get knocked down.
That's what he did.
Yeah,
too.
But you know,
he did.
He did what he had to do.
It just happens.
But there was a once instagram where
you're mocking deontay wilder technique,
legs coming up off the ground when he
was punching.
I actually like him,
but you know what?
You gotta do what you gotTa do that for.
I liked him actually.
I think he could fight.
I think he's very talented.
I think he's dangerous to anybody,
including myself.
He's a vicious puncher.
He's a wild puncture.
He's the one of those bony,
strong.
Those bony dudes hit your boy.
Woo.
You finished.
You know what I mean?
So he's dangerous.
He's,
he can punch,
um,
you know,
he kinda like,
he got that he offended me because I
don't give a shit,
you know what I'm saying?
But he kind of took it personal that I
was coming after him and I wasn't,
you know,
I'm a jokester.
I like to have fun and bug out.
He kind of took it like a little bit
like,
Oh,
you know this and I'm like,
I ain't like that.
You don't want.
I'm not a,
I'm not a street dude,
but I really am.
It could be whatever you want me to be
[inaudible] I'm from the street,
you know what I'm saying?
But I was like,
don't do that.
You know what?
Because trying to get busy,
if you touch me,
if you make me,
if you put me to that point in the
street anywhere,
I'm known now and I don't want to be.
I'm not that type of person,
but I'll defend the champ because I got
make.
I went to my babies.
I love them.
You feel me?
So I ain't gonna let nobody ever hurt
the chap.
Did you ever see that video where
deontay wilder box,
some Internet troll shit.
Yeah.
That guy's fucking crazy.
I'm a knock the wall down.
He gonna get.
I'm gonna get.
I'm a,
I'm a knockout Lucas Brown and then I'm
going to let a Deontae beyonce wild.
The beyonce,
beyonce.
You know what I'm saying?
Put up his BC belt and I'm a knock flat.
Starch out starch.
I would like to see that.
Yeah,
I would like to see the fight for sure.
Let's go chat and let's go check this
out.
Yeah,
exactly.
Now when you're 45 years old in
December,
December fourth,
realistically,
how much more time you think you're
going to be fighting after now called
Brown and um,
hopefully I'll get the window clinical
with a in Joshua,
anthony,
Joshua who a tremendous talent.
Um,
after that,
you know,
uh,
go after 'em,
whoever,
whoever has the belt,
man,
I'm going to keep.
Larry Holmes said,
don't stop by rehearsing.
Larry told me,
don't stop.
He said,
keep fighting.
Switch.
You do make money.
Have Fun.
Enjoy your life.
And who's having more fun with me?
Everywhere I go,
champion will be your happy.
They're motivated and that's,
that's to me,
it's for the first time in my life gives
me some purpose.
Other than making money,
I've been struggling to make money since
I came home from school and then have a
place to live for once in my life.
For once in my life I'm doing something
that's not involved.
Me using the money from her fight to buy
a car and look fair to you.
And then,
you know,
hang out.
I'm just being myself.
I'm a bump champs or bump.
I don't know what I'm saying.
I don't buy.
I refused because that was part of my
downfall,
you know,
wanting things,
wanting material things.
So finding,
finding power and things like that to
make myself feel good.
I'm going to go buy a new car.
I'm going to buy chain.
I'm gonna.
Buy a hat.
Buy this expensive 50 sweater now the
champ.
Don't do none of that shit.
The champ.
Just like a bump.
This is me.
You know what I'm saying?
Because I'm not putting value in that
anymore.
Which means what?
What I'm finding so amazing is that
everywhere I go,
people are saying,
hey jim,
thanks for the videos,
man.
We love you,
Can I get a picture?
Can I get a video that nothing can outdo
that shift?
Because I'd had a little bit of money.
Never made a lot of money.
Like those guys were hundreds of
millions of dollars,
but I made a little bit of money for me
to feel good.
You know what I'm saying?
But I never felt love.
No.
My mom was in the streets trying to put
a roof over our head.
I never had a dad.
You know what I'm saying?
I never had a brother and sister.
I was basically on my own.
You know,
you look at my personality,
you can tell.
I've watched a lot of television.
I grew up reading comic books and
cartoons,
so I never had love and to have what I
feel is love from people who genuinely
don't know me and just see me and say,
man,
thank you.
Two emails.
That's,
that's more fulfilling than anything
I've ever felt.
You feel me?
I do feel.
Yeah,
I think it's important,
man.
I think your message is important and
what you're saying about having all that
bullshit,
all the material possessions and
counting on it,
you know,
I remember Chuck d talking about that
once,
you know,
it was during the height of when people
have giant wheels and they're fucking
cars and every all in that room and he
was like,
he was like,
I drive a Ford explorer and he's like in
a it,
I don't put any,
any power in that
shit at all.
So sad that I was a slave to it.
I feel so miserable when I think about
the days that I spent money on sweaters,
caused jewelry bottles at the club.
I'm just like,
Damn what a lot of athletes go broke
trying to keep up with the Joneses,
but it's part of,
as part of our culture because we never
had shit.
Right.
So now we're like,
you're feeling good because someone's
admiring you for anything.
The admiration is what becomes
intoxicated.
You know,
what I'm fighting for me was that as
well.
You know,
I'm,
I'm finding on gratitude,
gratitude things that,
you know,
I,
I was smart though because I've always
wanted to keep a place,
a roof over my head and I'll put value
in that as well.
But you do a lot of the things too is
just for show it off other people and
that once I was able to get past that
and that was,
you know,
part of me was cutting my hair.
You don't have it locked for 27 years
and people want to come over here.
Man,
just the response from people was just,
it was amazing.
Just the people looking at me like,
wow,
look at you.
You cut your hair,
you finish.
You'll never get.
You'll never be nothing or boxes over
for you.
Why do you think you cut your hair?
Oh,
it was the sickest thing.
It was like the most eye opening thing
and people were literally like,
I could.
They were telling me,
but I could also see deeper into what
they were saying.
Like,
you're finished.
You'll never make another movie.
You never fight.
You're just like you.
That was your marketing tool that you
would just your head.
I was like,
no,
I can really fight.
I was like,
no,
I really got hands and they were like,
you know,
and no one believed in me,
so that's what makes this thing even
more powerful than the fact that I got
rid of that here and I'm still doing my
thing.
I'm still a child.
Weird thing to,
for people to focus on dreadlocks
marketing.
They looked at it like it was a
It was back in the day that was a big
part of who you were and they always
marketed your hair.
Right.
The crazy dreadlocks.
Right,
right,
right.
I understand,
but I don't want to stay because.
Yeah,
you really know me that that's just
nothing.
That was mark and again,
the hair was blocking me that he was
blocking my vibe because I was like,
Yo,
this haircut,
the hair had his own personality,
his own personality and then it's really
shit.
And then cutting the hair and see how
people treated me.
I was like,
you know what?
It's cool.
I'm gonna just,
I'm just gonna be me.
You know,
I'm not going to try to talk,
uh,
correct or you know what I'm saying?
My Dick,
my Dick,
she is going to be what it's going to
be.
People telling me.
Oh,
Shannon,
why don't you do movies?
Why don't you do this chant when I don't
speak Welsh?
Yeah,
I'm hardcore ghetto.
If you want to go into every word you're
saying that your champion.
I said,
you know what I mean,
I'm not the type you feel me.
I'm just keeping it real.
Like I've learned one thing in.
Shout out to Chris Morris.
Stay in your lane,
you know,
and that's one of his best sayings that
I hear him say it all the time,
but it's true.
I learned that stay in my lane champion.
Don't know what you're really good at.
Really good at being Shannon.
Let's go.
That's it.
And that took me that.
You'll get one more time.
No,
and I mean that because that's what I
did know who I didn't know who I was.
I grew up overnight.
What's understandable?
I mean,
it takes a long time for everybody if
everything's worked out perfectly
released,
man,
everybody,
every person that's ever lived know you
don't want.
No one ever fails.
If you do your full,
if you mean if you're 18 years old,
you've got it all figured out and get
the fuck out of here.
That own apartment.
I was like 15,
right?
So I was like,
not my problem when I was 15 and was
like,
uh,
I was a,
we call it when you are living in the
place you're squatting in a sense.
But you know,
I was like,
I've been on my own all my life.
A friend of mine's just Robinson said to
me one day,
he said,
you know,
Jack,
you basically been making your own
decisions since she was a kid,
but now you understand yourself better.
I didn't know who the fuck I was.
Right?
I didn't know who I was.
I was just knew that I was living.
But going through all the bad times,
I think it's probably what has made your
character so strong today and now that
everything's good,
you you understand the importance of
keeping it good.
That's why this positive message that
you keep pumping out.
And that's why this.
Let's go chat.
I'm one step away from.
I'm one step away,
a fruit punch from not feeling good.
I went to Roscoe's yesterday,
you know,
great for getting waffles and I had a.
I took a sip of the.
What's it called?
Eliminate Sunrise.
I don't know.
The fruit punch and sugary shit got me
thinking bad.
I was like,
Oh man,
I feel terrible.
Like so again,
I say that you say I want a path and
that's the great power.
But so is so crucial.
Diet's important.
Who I'm around.
It's important.
You feel what I'm saying?
Because that's the energy you feel me
and I'm around somebody doing some
negative shit.
I'm not on that.
So I don't need to be around this
person.
I don't even listen to like that much
hip hop.
I listen to beats.
I don't eat because I don't want to hear
you drinking,
smoking.
You want to screw this girl,
you this shoot that you got this,
you got this car.
I got the watch.
I don't need that chip.
I already went through that and that was
a bad portion of my life.
The nineties is something that I wish
never had.
The Guy,
I can't remember.
The name isn't until four years ago.
I don't feel like I was alive.
Wow.
Yeah.
I don't feel like I was lying and that's
credit to my,
to my family,
man,
my wife and kids,
they really helped me down.
I'm crazy channel.
I'm not just saying no act.
I'm really.
I've been through some shit so I been
through some shit.
Man.
You know what is on that crazy music you
play in the background that's just beats
tramp shout out to the plow.
Lord o g tags.
It was just beats Krazy k,
all the people,
man.
You know what I'm saying?
Courtney,
Scott,
all the people.
She's a female from La makes beats.
She's amazing.
I mean this is these.
I had to like do a detox,
like I don't watch certain things.
Television,
you know,
you flicking the channel.
What you got first 48,
a lockup.
You got negativity news.
I don't.
I had to.
I had to do a detox from the news.
Lately.
I don't watch anymore news.
The presidential election.
All this shit is going crazy.
I don't want to be involved in on
because I'm involved with something
else.
Roxanne,
I'm focused on Lucas Brown.
I can't focus on trump and hilary.
I got focused on Shannon breaks and me
and Lucas locking ass.
Whenever we get a date you feel me.
So I've learned to like put things in
perspective for you.
I can't watch the internet and watch so
much brutal knockout videos and this
girl is doing that in this guy I don't
need to be involved with that.
I had and that's what a lot of people
need to learn and they and a lot of
people follow me or kids and they say
thanks champ.
Because once I see the most damaging
thing right now and America around the
world for get that around the world is
that kids don't have guidance.
You know what I mean?
So they got uncle champ.
You feel me?
Some kids,
thousands of kids hit me like you're
like a dad to me,
man.
You know what I mean?
I didn't have a data.
Have a role model.
I didn't have nothing.
So they looked at my videos were days.
I don't want to make videos.
Joe,
I get text chat.
You okay?
Chad,
we haven't heard from you in a couple of
days.
So I have a responsibility now to help
others make them feel happy by being
happy sometimes when I don't even feel
happy.
But I think one of the things you're
saying it's really important that you're
talking about a mental diet as well as a
physical 100 percent.
And I think you really do have a mental
diet and if you just take it,
nothing but negative things all day and
around negative people.
And especially when you just expose
yourself to 7 billion people's worth of
news.
And the only stuff that gets popular as
and stuff that's fucked up.
Nasty Shit Bro.
Fuck with your head.
Nasty.
I mean it really not forget your head
because then it physically started
feeling like,
I felt so crazy with this election.
You know what I'm saying?
Like physically,
I was like,
man.
you know what?
That's it.
I came home and said,
that shit no more.
I said,
I told my wife.
I said No.
I said,
please do me a favor if you want to
watch this stuff,
do me a favor,
please just Tivo it and watch it when
the champs on around.
Because I can't.
It's really me because I got to worry
about training.
Right?
I gotta think I gotta think about that.
I don't want to be worried about what
they,
what they do happen.
Gonna Happen.
You know what?
I ain't gonna you don't,
it's going to affect me or it's not
gonna affect me.
I'm going to deal with that then.
But right now I've got to focus on me
and that's what I couldn't do.
Champ.
And I don't,
I don't blame anybody,
but if you out there on prescription
drugs,
I was taking all types of inhalers all
my life since I promise team from early
days kids.
That stuff is bad for you.
Mentally chat isn't bad for you
mentally,
man.
What does it do for a man?
The anxiety,
the Judas,
the brain,
the chemistry,
the what it does to your brain,
man.
It alters it champ.
All you got to be careful not to take
your medicine.
Follow your doctors.
I'm not telling you you don't listen to
doctors,
but me personally,
I had to go on a journey to find out how
to save me because I went to every
doctor.
They don't know anything about hormones
and this and that.
They don't know anything.
They don't know how you.
I heard you once say you want to find
about your hormones.
It's a super old doctor that looks
great,
that knows about this type of shit
because when you're feeling depressed
and your testosterone is like 80 or 20,
you feel like killing yourself champ.
You've got to do something.
People can't give you a bunch of pills
and say,
this will make you feel better.
It's because you're still going to have
low test,
which for a man is gonna,
make you feel like a bitch.
Excuse my language,
but it's just a fact.
So all these different factors play a
role.
And also again,
back to what you're saying,
what you're watching,
the mental diet.
If you're watching people getting killed
all day,
you're gonna feel a certain way.
It's all this shit is going on in your
brain and your mental stores.
You feel me and now you're just
wondering why.
Then you're eating sugar.
He eating cookies and donuts and fast
food and Chinese food.
This shit ain't helping you weave the
champ and that's what I'm telling people
everyday,
champ,
leave it alone.
It's too tempting.
Everywhere you go,
you see fast food.
Take take the food home and cook it
yourself.
We've got to try to bet and it's not in.
The problem is it's not cheap,
but we can afford to go to whole foods
every day,
right?
You know what I'm saying?
Who can ice hard?
I'm struggling.
Who can afford every day to spend $150,
$20 for their family a day,
every day.
That shit is hard chat.
I think what you're saying is very
important.
Very,
very important about a mental and a
physical diet.
That is.
It's the same thing in that like when
you watch it all the violence on
television or all the negative news,
it's like sugar.
Very compelling and to take in and for
you.
Well,
I had that sugar drink last night and I
was like,
because I'm not used to it.
Right?
And I was like,
I was feeling.
I was like,
Yo,
chill.
This is what people drinking every day,
all day every day.
And I was happy.
I was.
I able to do it now I can't take a sip.
It's crazy how your body adjusts your
body,
your body adapts to not having sugar and
feeling healthy.
And then when you do have something
that's unhealthy you,
you feel it.
Like you really feel deep in your body
and your mood change me,
I crashed.
Yeah man.
I had a cheeseburger and a milkshake
man,
and it was like somebody hit me with a
tranquilizer dart.
I felt terrible telling you,
bro,
it's crazy.
Before I would eat that and it'd be
nothing crazy,
but I think what you're saying I think
is very important for people to take in.
You know,
and having a person like you who's
experienced these great highs and lows
and then come out of it with this
positive energy.
That is that.
That is so powerful for people.
That's such a motivational thing for
other people though,
man.
There's no other way.
Yeah.
As much as you are helping yourself and
I know you're helping yourself,
you're helping a lot of people,
man.
You really helping each other
helping each other.
I mean,
honestly,
there's nothing I said from the
beginning that this ain't mine.
Are Patented.
Trademark the name.
I mean I trademarked the same and
everything you trademark.
Let's go chat to try and go to.
Let's go back.
Had to,
you know,
I had so many ups and downs.
Like I told you when I tell you no lie
bro,
I got nothing to lie to you about.
I was involved with some major deals
when I'm talking about from at the top
in the beginning and in business and
entertainment and the champion come out
on the good side.
So a lot of times,
a lot of times enough to say damn,
I already am,
I stupid or something like,
but you don't just trust and belief and
getting shot at champs and dirty
business,
dirty game show and it's been dirty for
businesses,
all businesses.
So that's what I learned in and you
know,
coming out where I am now and you know,
I trademarked it because I said,
you know what it was,
it was starting to like,
you know,
physical.
When I was like,
I was really passionate about it because
it's something that I was saying again,
I have nobody around me to whites to
have friends with me all the time.
I'm training,
whatever,
whatever.
They all left.
It was always moved on.
So for me I was like no entourage,
nobody to push me.
I've got to push myself.
So I started talking to myself something
that I ever did and that's a whole
nother story.
I'm gonna tell you in the book why I
refused to talk to myself.
Why does your friends tell me I was
saving it for Book Chalky,
but I'm still really sell the book man.
Let me know.
Put up links.
I let people know,
right?
Well I'm buying myself if we go in that
route,
that already they'll come on.
No,
no,
no.
The reason why is because um,
I had an uncle,
my mother's brother Anthony part hand,
he was her only brother.
He went to the military.
He went to the Vietnam war as a child,
you know,
as a young man,
18 years old.
When he left high school,
he didn't have to because it was all
sisters and he wanted to be Kogi.
He wanted to go because everyone in
town,
Petersburg,
Virginia,
excuse me,
Jarret,
Virginia,
everybody from his town,
the young men were going his own cousins
and everybody.
So he went,
he came back,
I'm disturbed.
He came back,
you know,
different than when he went in.
He was actually missing for quite a time
that we could declare him dead when he
showed up one day,
um,
with a trench coat on army boots and
neck it.
Whoa,
whoa.
Easy street in Brooklyn.
So this led to him being mentally
disturbed all my life.
He would talk to himself.
He lived with us.
I,
I slept in a twin bed here and he slept
in the bed there and he was with
alcohol.
He drank.
He became very violent,
you know,
he beat my mom up one time.
Really bad colds.
I had eyes on him talking to himself,
but something I grew up all my life
watching and I'm like,
ain't me crazy.
You called amy,
amy,
you crazy.
Okay.
You told me to itself so.
And I got older.
I would just refuse to even have a
conversation with myself.
Oh,
you're crazy if you.
And four years ago I started having
conversations with myself.
I was like,
Yo,
you know what,
champ,
you got to go.
And I start saying,
let's go champ.
And I was like,
ma'am,
I asked my wife.
I said,
you think I'm crazy?
Because I spoke.
She was like,
Oh yeah,
we already know.
You're crazy.
Know what I mean?
So I'm like,
let's go you.
And that was my mantra.
It became a mantra.
You know,
my friend told me one of his mantras was
to be the man,
you've got to be the man.
When he was tired,
he was running mile 18 to be the man.
You've got to be the man,
be the man.
You got to be the man I'm going to say
to himself.
And I was like,
you know why they the mantra and I was
hitting the bag one day and I was tired.
I was like 400 pounds.
I was like,
let's go champ champ.
You know,
and it's in the head champ.
when I'm feeling pain,
you're feeling pain,
you're feeling down,
tell yourself,
let's go champ.
Let's go chat to what I hear you when I
work out.
Sometimes it's yours.
I shouldn't push them through a set.
It's yours,
it's yours.
It's everybody's.
It's the people's man,
the people.
The people gave me this.
The universe gave me this.
The people,
the people linked into it and it's not
mine.
It's ours,
we just want to give each other
positivity and love and I meet people
from everywhere.
China.
I'm a little nuts because I go to every
city or country and people say,
chair,
but I'm in the lobby or I'm in this
time,
can I meet you?
And I said,
come over to the hotel and they come.
They come.
I mean,
you might have to stop that when you
went to people.
I'm the people's champ.
I'm fair.
I'm here for the people.
Wow Man,
that's strong.
But listen,
if you can motivate yourself,
you can.
I mean,
you motivate other people.
You should definitely be able to
motivate yourself as well.
I'm not trying going to be honest with
you.
I'm not trying to like say I'm a guru.
I'm a motivator.
I'm just a dude who is showing people
that I was down and out.
I was flat on my face.
I wanted to kill myself and I gave.
I didn't give up for the love of my
family and the love of the people.
That's pr.
That's Sam.
Let's go champion that.
Believe in me.
I want to do a full of them.
You need a reason,
you know,
unit purpose.
Got Her shout out to Scott Hirsch.
He told me a long time ago.
He said,
uh,
you know,
Shaney,
I think the family thing,
environment is just out the blue and the
conversation.
He just said,
you know,
Shana,
we wouldn't even talking about anything.
He said,
you know,
I just think the family,
the family plays a huge part of our
development.
I said,
why you say that,
Scott?
He says,
because it gives you a reason to go home
at night.
And I was like,
Damn,
you know,
we all need a reason.
You know what I mean?
There's a reason and my family gives me
a reason and you give me a reason
because when snoop dogg gave me a reason
to camera on,
gave me a reason every popular rapper
and unpopular wrapper and guys who make
beats,
they gave me a reason because champion,
feel good,
man.
I'm a keep it real with you.
A lot of days I didn't feel good,
but when I got up and seen you,
what?
Snoop or cameron or reals or chance or
anybody out there that I know that was
gave me a shot out or did that,
uh,
you know,
actors to someone else.
I was like,
Dad gave me a reason and the reason it
became more and more so I felt like I
was taking an imagery from the people
around the world.
Every,
every text,
every meme,
every,
every DM I feel I'm getting stronger
because now the people behind me,
I never had nothing.
So I was on my own.
I was a kid by myself and now I've got
the world behind me.
That's all I needed.
You got a lot of people got the world
champ.
I don't know.
I got 150 thanks to you as well.
And then everybody who promotes me and
those are my promoters by the way.
The people promote me.
Thanks.
So you guys got 157,000
people,
a hundred 50,
6,000
people following me.
Right.
That to me is unreal.
I started out with nine.
I remember when you talked about me on
your instagram because we were talking
about you and how much I love your
videos.
I was like,
oh,
I'm excited.
This is excitement for me because I
never had this.
I never had no momentum.
I never had nobody behind me.
I got a reason.
I feel like rocky.
You know what I'm saying?
Like keep fighting.
Hey,
I got a reason.
You know what I mean?
I've never had a reason except to try to
make some money to feed myself and my
family or to show off or get some shit.
You know what I'm saying?
So me,
vo reached type of situation.
Now I'm too.
I don't care about the money.
Of course I got to have the money.
Don't get me wrong and I want to be paid
accordingly.
I'm bringing non boxing fans to boxing.
That deserves something.
I told you when I fought Vitaly
Klitschko,
they did the highest ratings ever,
not because of political,
because of shared and breaks.
He fought many people.
Why so many with me when I fought
limits,
fluids,
highest ratings when I fought George
Foreman,
George foreman,
highest ratings.
I sell champ.
Now.
I want to be.
I want to be paid for that chip.
This is a job.
You know me.
I'm a mailman.
I get up everyday and go to work,
do my job,
but I want to be paid.
I didn't get paid when a forklift go,
champ.
I want to make money.
I'm not stupid.
You feel me?
I was,
but I'm not your primary motivation.
My primary motivation is to.
People are behind me and I want to do
something that never been gone.
I want to bring all these non boxing
fans like Muhammad Ali did.
I wanted my Hammad lead moment,
not for me and for my ego because I
don't have.
I cut the hill already.
I got a girl already.
I got a wife.
I don't care.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't care about clothes.
I don't want a Bentley.
I don't want to.
I don't care about that no more.
I don't want none of that.
I just want the people to say that make
me feel good champ.
That'll make me feel good man.
And it make me feel like,
you know what,
my mom looking at me and she could say
my part of my boy,
you feel me?
He made somebody nothing.
You know,
we was homeless.
People turn their back on US champ.
They wouldn't let us come in a place.
Many nights we sat on the train and many
nights I didn't know when she was alive
or dead,
you know,
and I was hoping to just.
And it was rough man.
And I want her to look at me and say,
man,
my boy made it.
You know what I mean?
And she said something before she died.
She said,
Shannon,
when we lost everything,
people said,
you know,
she said she was like,
the big person in my family was supposed
to do something.
This is all in the book,
but she was supposed to be something and
she got.
She came to New York and she was living
in life and she was making a,
got a job and she got put on.
She got got on drugs and she went from a
beautiful woman to a woman who lost
everything,
but she had a son and she took me sickly
and all stuck by my side,
so I said,
I'm gonna make it,
and she instilled in me making Shannon
regardless of what you have to do,
make it.
And when people turned our back on us
and we had nothing,
Joe,
she says,
Shannon,
one day we going to have something and
they gonna look at us different,
you feel me?
And she said to me before died.
So I didn't make
it,
but I made it through you and that's
what I'm doing is for because she made
it because she gave me.
She made it her son and she doesn't want
me to give up asthma.
Ain't no excuse.
No manager.
Ain't no excuse,
no promoter.
Ain't no excuse.
Make it until I came out with social
media.
They can on social media and I'm making
the champ.
When you making a lot of people happy to
thank you.
A lot of excitement,
a lot of motivation,
a lot of enthusiasm.
Me,
I'm in your corner corner.
Thank you chairman.
Thank you for being.
This is a.
I'm sorry to cut you off.
No,
nothing.
I'm just saying I had a great fucking
time talking to you.
This has been therapeutic for me.
More importantly because I didn't need
to vent because no one's been able to
give me a outlet.
No SPEC.
Normally.
This big has given me an opportunity to
talk to so many people and I wish I
could've done this totally different
now.
Perfect.
This is perfect.
I started out a little,
you know,
tripping up,
but it's all good.
Champ.
You know.
Um,
this is a moment from your life because
forget the past.
I don't even remember.
I got,
I got some type of damage.
I don't ever killed.
Remember this shit.
This right.
This moment,
right now is the moment,
man.
I'm in the moment,
I'm in the moment and I appreciate it
because it means a lot to me,
man,
because I was flat.
They nobody wanted to get me nothing.
Nobody gave me a shot.
I couldn't get a tee shirt called
everlasting sent man.
Let me get a tee shirt.
It said no.
Call Back Man,
don't go here with that shit.
Shit.
I couldn't get nothing from nobody,
man.
I don't want nothing from nobody.
You what I'm saying,
Oh,
I want to do is be successful.
You know,
have something for my family when I'm
gone.
You know what I'm saying?
So they don't have to suffer the way I
did and I want to make people laugh and
make people have fun and be so.
Leave my fight to say,
man,
he did it.
Then I'm going to do it again.
That's another thing.
Before I go,
I want to say this.
I want to fight a lot.
I want the heavyweight championship
fight three,
four,
five times a year.
I don't believe in this fight.
Two years.
He should fight every fight,
every fight,
every six weeks.
That champion,
yes.
That's what should be happening and
that's what I want.
I want to be an active campaign.
Now.
I'll give that to wilder.
They did keep them busy before he,
before he hurt his arm,
they kept him busy.
But that's how you're supposed to fight
the game.
Be Busy,
be busy half for bringing more people to
the sport and then walk away.
Followed us on instagram.
It will make your life happier.
Let's go try to address the instagram
address.
Oh my instagram is canon underscored
briggs.
Let's go.
You know that's my instagram and my
facebook is sweatshirt and breaks.
Shannon Brennan,
twitter is the Canon,
the Canon Briggs on twitter,
man.
And my website is [inaudible] dot com.
Let's go champion.
Buy a t shirt.
Man,
I'm on my own channel.
I appreciate y'all.
I'm not using the money for nothing.
That's for.
That's for you.
I'm wearing this.
You know what I mean?
Shout out to my baby girl chloe Mumu.
Fat chairing and catering and my wife.
I'm on.
I love you babe.
Shout out to everybody that's.
If you don't mind me giving shout outs.
Shout it out.
Shout outs.
Shout out.
Chris is Chris Junior.
Stacy Amea.
Mon.
Everybody from brooklyn,
brownsville.
I lovE y'all around the world.
A la,
compton,
watts.
Oh everybody.
My man.
Oh paolo out there.
Jamal,
jamal,
cheesy.
Everybody in the coolest.
Show me these other things,
but I really want to thank you because
bro,
I made it.
I made it again.
I made it before,
but I made it again.
I'm this.
This is a sign that I'm back.
You're back.
I'm Back.
Let's go chat.
Thank you everybody.
That was beautiful.
Thank you Chad.